Well, greetings and thank you all for
being here, especially if this is your
first time with us, Adventist or
otherwise. So, the formal topic for
tonight's
debate, do Christians need to keep the
seventh day
Sabbath? Do Christians need to keep the
seventh day Sabbath? And with us to
debate the subject are two
pastors. Taking the affirmative tonight
is 7th Adventist pastor Jose Leaporte.
Pastor Leaporte is first and foremost a
follower of Jesus Christ and an avid
student of the word. He received his BA
in theology from Southwestern Adventist
University and has finished an MA in
theological studies from Southern
Adventist University, my alma mater. Oo
oo. He is an ordained minister of the
7th avenist church, a local church
pastor and has been a revival speaker,
evangelist and teacher in various
settings. He loves to teach hermeneutics
and ex Jesus to leoty and is grateful to
be married to his lovely wife of 16
years with whom he shares a wonderful
daughter. And taking the negative
tonight is reformed Baptist pastor and
apologist Tony Costa. Pastor Costa
received his BA and MA from the
University of Toronto and a PhD in
theology and New Testament from Radbound
University uh Nagan in the Netherlands.
He is an ordained minister and the
pastor of Parklon Baptist Church in
Toronto, Ontario. He is a member of the
Evangelical Theological Society and
lectures in universities, colleges, and
seminaries in both North America and
overseas. He is the author of Worship
and the Risen Jesus in the Pauline
Letters, Early Christian Creeds and
Hymns, and he just recently published
his new book, No King But Christ. Tony
is married to a wonderful wife, is a
father of three children, and has a
grandson with another on the way. So
that is the lowdown on our interlocators
tonight. The agenda for tonight will be
as follows. Each individual will have 10
minutes uninterrupted to give their
opening statement and present their
case.
This will be followed by five minute
rebuttals where each participant will
have five minutes uninterrupted to
respond to the other side's opening. The
key there being to respond to the other
side, not five more minutes of opening.
After that, we will transition into the
crossexamination, which will consist of
four 20 minute intervals. Each side will
get two rounds of 20 minutes to
question, examine, and dialogue with the
other side controlling and leading the
time. This will then conclude with
closing statements where each
interlocutor will have five minutes
uninterrupted to give their final
remarks. We will then end the night with
roughly 15 or so minutes of audience
getting of the of you all in the
audience getting to interact with the
debaters by way of audience questions.
To submit a question, send it through as
a super chat in the live chat. These can
be sent through at any time during the
debate and they will automatically be
sorted on our end and easily organized
for us to begin tackling. Uh we will
answer them or the guest will uh in the
order that they come in at. Now, please
specify within your question which
debater it is for. Each individual will
will receive one minute to answer the
question beginning with the individual
that the question is for. This is to
make sure that both parties get to
engage. If questions happen to only come
in for one of the parties. If we have no
super chat questions, the night will
simply be concluded after the closing
statements. I will be neutally
moderating tonight. So, please, please,
please, no questions for the moderator.
With that said, gentlemen, thank you
both for being here. My pleasure.
So, one final thing. Sorry about that,
Jose. One final thing before we begin
with Jose's opening statement. I will
audibly inform you when there is one
minute left of your time during any
given portion of the debate. At the end
of the time, I will announce such. If
you're in the middle of a thought, feel
free to finish that thought. If either
of you need scripture brought up during
the cross exam, simply state that you'd
like a certain text brought up when it
is your control time and it will be
brought up on screen for you as quickly
as possible to keep the time useful and
keep things going. Any questions before
we begin?
All right. Well, Jose, let let me get
the time set up here. And the time will
be yours when you begin speaking, sir.
And your five minute or sorry, I take
that back. Your 10m minute opening will
begin when you begin speaking, sir.
Okay. Well, this one's not my
presentation. That's That's mine. Uh,
yep. There we go.
All right.
Well, before we even start, can I just
say thank you gentlemen uh for the
opportunity to do this with you guys.
This is a real privilege and welcome to
everybody who's here. Uh I'm going to
get started and I'll just let Miles know
when to change uh due to some technical
difficulties this slide. So, thank you
guys. All right, here we
go. Uh I don't see my slide up there, so
I'm assuming it already is. All right,
very well. All right, here we
go. Do Christians need to keep uh the
seventh day Sabbath? Well, in order to
let's go next on the slide there. In
order to make sure we're not talking
past each other, let's make sure we talk
about what I believe are points of
agreement. First of all, salvation is by
grace through faith alone. I think we
agree on that. I think we also agree
obedience is an outgrowth of the saved.
I also believe that we believe Saturday
is the biblical Sabbath. And I think we
also agree that Christians are under the
new covenant. Now what are our areas of
disagreement next? Um ultimately I
believe it lies on what does the new
covenant entail and do Christians need
to be obedient to the ten commandments?
Are they bound to the Sabbath
commandment? Next. So the question is
what is the new covenant? Next. In
essence, as I look at the new covenant,
at the center of it is the story of our
redemption, our salvation. But also,
you'll find in scripture that we're
looking at type meeting anti-ype. Next,
if you look at Matthew 26, you have
Jesus in Passover inaugurating the new
covenant with his blood, which is shed
for many for the remissions of sins.
Therefore, we see there that the
beginning of the new covenant is about
forgiveness. It's about cleansing of
sin. However, if we go a little further
into the book of Hebrews next, which I
believe is Pauline in theology. I know
there's some debate about that among
some scholars, uh, but I believe it
still bears Pauline theology. It
mentions that Jesus is the mediator of a
better covenant which was established on
better promises. And and I see a
comparison there with Galatians 3 where
Paul makes it clear that the law does
not trump the promises of God. And yet
we want an explanation of the new
covenant. Next, how can we see what the
new covenant is? Well, that is further
found in Hebrews 8:7-13. text. For if
that first covenant had been faultless,
the Bible says, then no place would have
been sought for a second, because
finding fault with them, he says,
behold, the days are coming, says the
Lord, when I will make a new covenant
with the house of Israel and the house
of Judah. Next, not according to the
covenant that I made with their fathers,
for this is the covenant that I will
make with the house of Israel after
those days, says the Lord. I will put my
laws in their mind and write them on
their hearts. I will be their God and
they shall be my people. Similar to 2
Corinthians 3 where Paul talks about the
spirit letter of the law writing things
in our hearts. Next, the Bible continues
to say, "None of them shall teach his
neighbor and none his brother, saying
know the Lord. For all shall know me
from the least of the greatest of them,
for I will be merciful to them
righteousness and their sins and their
lawless deeds I will remember no more."
I mean, here's part of that new
covenant. This is eternal life. they
might know you the only true God and
Jesus Christ whom you have sent knowing
his mission his purpose in your life and
knowing his law. We continue in that he
says a new covenant has been made and
the first is obsolete now. Now what is
becoming obsolete and growing old is
ready to vanish away. Next, I want you
to notice that Hebrews 8:8-12 is a
citation of Jeremiah 31, which is that
the new covenant was prophesied in the
Hebrew scriptures. The old covenant
prophesied of the new covenant. Now,
notice a few things next with me. First
of all, the old covenant was made with
Israel. And so, the new covenant as well
in Hebrews 8, Jeremiah 31 was also made
with Israel. I hear people say, "Well,
the old covenant is just for Israel."
the Sabbath is just a sign for Israel.
I'm sitting here going, "Well, wait a
second. If you're going to apply that
and just say it's just for Israel, it
doesn't matter." Then what about the new
covenant? Maybe the new covenant doesn't
apply to me because it was made with
Israel. Next, you can also notice the
old covenant talks about making God's
law binding, but the new covenant
ratifies God's law in the hearts of
humanity. So, some key points next that
we can look at. God's law has not
changed based on what I'm seeing here.
And God himself doesn't change next. So
what exactly changed from the old to the
new covenant? Well, type met anti-ype.
Symbol met reality. The parable is now
fully being revealed. Let's go to the
next slide. Hebrews 9 talks about the
symbolism that pointed to Christ.
Hebrews 8 mentions the shadows. Hebrews
10, the shadows. These are parabas, the
parable of gifts, sacrifices, uh, uh,
food and drinks, various washings,
fleshly ordinances. Kind of sounds like
Galosians 2:16, Galatians 4:9 and 10.
Well, because we're talking similar
things. Also, I want to parallel Hebrews
8 and the new covenant with something
that scholars have also paralleled with
next. He Ezekiel chapter 36 when it
talks about giving Israel a new heart, a
new spirit, it says, "I will put my
spirit within you." This is the
outpouring of the Holy Spirit. What will
happen? It'll cause you to walk in my
statutes, keep my judgments, and do
them. Now, you say, "Well, the law's not
mentioned there. The commandments aren't
mentioned there." But statutes and
judgments, when you see that in the old
covenant, you see that connected with
the law. For example, next Genesis 26:5,
Abraham obeyed my voice, kept my charge,
my commands, my statutes, my laws. Now,
this is before Mount Si and and I
understand my opponent's going to say
that, well, the law was revealed at
Mount Si, but this seems to imply that
Abraham already had some verbal oral
transmission of God's commandments,
statutes, laws. Perhaps Mount Si was a
further revelation for the actual nation
of Israel written in stone. Next, this
is the same Abraham who is justified by
faith. Paul quotes Genesis 15:6 that
Abraham believed God and was accounted
to him for righteousness. And yet next,
this is the Abraham who obeyed God's
laws and kept his commandments. That's
interesting. And so the question is
next, is there a tension between faith
and the law? Well, Paul clarifies in
Romans 3, do we then make void the law
through faith? Certainly not. On the
contrary, we establish the law. Next,
what shall we say? He says in Romans
7:7, is the law sin? Certainly not. When
you see certainly not, that is the
strongest way in the Greek to say
absolutely not. He says, "I wouldn't
have known sin except through the law."
Which he gives an example. The law says,
"You shall not covet." Direct citation
of the 10 commandments. Let's keep
going. Next, the Romans 7:12 says,
"Therefore, the law is holy. The
commandment holy and just and good." So
listen, I'm justified by faith by grace
alone. And yet, doesn't it make sense
that if God has justified me, then I
would want to live in what is holy and
what is just and what is good? I'm
wondering. Let's go to the next one.
Romans 3:20 makes it clear. We're not
justified by the deeds of the law, but
the law has a purpose, and that is to
point out what sin is. Moving on. Now,
some people will say, "What about the
law of Christ, Jesus commandments?"
Well, let's do a little systematic
theology for a moment and remember in
John 8:58, Jesus declared himself as the
I am next. In other words, he is the God
of the old covenant, the God of the new
covenant. He is the I am. He is Yahweh.
He is the creator. He wrote the ten
commandment law with his own fingers.
Next, that's what Exodus 31:18 points
out. The law was written in the Ten
Commandments on stone with the finger of
God. Next, the Ten Commandments. Thus
are Jesus's commandments, which is why
he is the Lord of the Sabbath. It is his
day, the Lord's day.
Next, as we go on, you can continue
seeing that justification by grace
through faith alone does not make void
the law. The law still identifies sin
and the need of a savior. Next, the
primary part of the law that defines sin
is the Ten Commandments. Notice in the
Ten Commandments, there's no Passover,
Day of Atonement. None of that is there.
But the Sabbath is part of one minute
that it does make it clear then that if
we willfully choose to disobey this law,
we are sinning. That is clear. So in
conclusion, as Paul said, what shall we
say then? Shall we continue in sin
breaking God's law that grace may
abound?
Absolutely not. So in conclusion, do
next, do Christians need to keep the
seventh day Sabbath? Answer, absolutely.
It's part of God's law. God hasn't
changed. His character hasn't changed.
His mission never changed. And thus, his
law does not change. That ten
commandment law placed in the ark of the
covenant. Notice the other laws were put
on the side of the covenant. There is
clear distinction that God gives to
these things. Thank you very much for
listening and I look forward next to you
having the opportunity of growing with
us this evening. God bless you. Perfect
timing. Time is up. All right. Thank you
for that. Jose Tony, you will have your
10-minute opening. Your time will begin
when you begin speaking, sir. Just one
second and I will get your slides
brought up and we will be good to go.
All right. All right, sir. Your time
will begin when you begin speaking. Very
good. Thank you so much. Okay. So, let's
uh begin here. Um are Christians
obligated to keep the seventh day
Sabbath today? So, the Sabbath is the
proper name in scripture for the seventh
day of the week. It does correspond to
our Saturday. Uh the question tonight is
not what day is the Sabbath, but whether
under the new covenant Christians are
obligated to keep it. And so my thesis
is to argue that the Sabbath is not
obligatory for Christians in the new
covenant. Genesis 2:2:3 tells us that
God on the seventh day finished his work
that he had done and he rested on the
seventh day from all his work that he
had done and he blessed the seventh day
and made it holy. Declares on it God
rested from almost work all his work
that he had done in creation. This verse
of course contains a very interesting
statement that God finished his creative
work on the six on the seventh day. He
sanctifies it. He blesses it. But if you
notice in Genesis 1, there is no evening
and morning preceding the seventh day.
There's an evening and morning for every
day of the week except the seventh day.
And the implication is that the seventh
day was supposed to be an eternal time
of rest with God. That is Adam and Eve
if they had not sinned would have
entered into God's rest immediately. But
instead of that, the fall occurs in
Genesis 3 and they come under the fall
and the curse of the fall and work
becomes toilsome. Note that there is no
commandment here for anyone to keep the
Sabbath. The first time that the word
Sabbath, Shabbat, appears in the Bible
is in Exodus 16:23. And it's in the
context of God bringing his people out
of Egypt. He brings them into the Sinai
desert. And there he reveals to them the
Sabbath day. He tells them to pick the
mana on every day of the week. A double
portion will come down on the sixth day
and they are to rest on the seventh day.
So the word Shabbat appears first in
scripture in Exodus 16 where God is
teaching the people of Israel his day of
rest, the day that they are to keep. And
in the ten commandments, that day of
course becomes the seal commandment of
the Mosaic covenant. Now in Nehemiah
chapter 9 13-14, we're told, "You came
down on Mount Si. You spoke to them from
heaven. You gave them regulations and
laws that are just and right and decrees
and commands that are good." You made
known to them your holy Sabbath and gave
them commands, decrees, and laws through
your servant Moses. Notice that God had
to make his Sabbath known to them. They
did not know the Sabbath. In fact, you
will not find anything in the book of
Genesis to suggest that Enoch or Noah or
the patriarchs or Joseph even kept the
Sabbath. But here we see that God
revealed the Sabbath. He made it known
to them on Mount Si as we read in Exodus
19 and 20. In Deuteronomy 5:2-3 uh Moses
recounts to the people in the recounting
of the decalogue the ten commandments
the Lord our God made a covenant with us
at Horeb that is mount si another name
for mount si it was not with our fathers
that the lord made this covenant but
with us with all of us who are alive
here today. So the covenant that God
made on Mount Si which included the ten
commandments he did not make this
covenant with the patriarchs with the
fathers Abraham, Isaac and Jacob, he did
not make that covenant with them. This
is a different covenant. This is a
Mosaic covenant is not the Abrahamic
covenant which is based on of course
better promises because they have
messianic promises. But this covenant
made on Sinai was made with us who are
alive here today. This is further
reinforced in Exodus 34 27-28. The Lord
said to Moses when Moses was told to um
go and receive a second copy of the ten
commandments, write these words for in
accordance with these words. I've made a
covenant with you and with Israel. So
notice again the context. This is a
covenant that God is making with Israel.
So he was there with the Lord 40 days
and 40 nights. He neither ate bread nor
drank water. And he wrote on the tablets
the words of the covenant, the ten
commandments. Notice the ten
commandments are the covenant of si. It
is the siatic covenant. It is part of
the Mosaic covenant. And it's not part
of the new covenant. It's part of the
Mosaic covenant. That's what Jeremiah 31
says. I'm going to make a new covenant
with them. It will not be like the
covenant I made with them at Horeb. That
covenant they broke. And so God is
telling us a new covenant is coming
which has come in Christ which is not
like the mount the uh covenant made at
Si. It's a better covenant not written
on stone tablets but written in people's
hearts. The Sabbath was a sign between
God and Israel. Exodus 31:13. You are to
speak to the people of Israel and say
above all you shall keep my Sabbaths for
this is a sign between me and you
throughout your generations that you may
know that I the Lord sanctify you. The
ten commandments are structured after
what we know as the treaty of the great
kings in the ancient near east. When a
king took over a certain people, he
would enter into a treaty with them.
Included in that treaty was a sign a
signed covenant associated with it. And
the signed covenant we find with Israel
is the Sabbath. And that is why the
Sabbath is the covenant sign of the
Mosaic covenant. All the covenants have
certain signs associated with them. This
is the Mosaic covenant as we have seen.
So in Matthew 11:28-30, Jesus tells us
who the real Sabbath is. It's not that I
keep the Sabbath, but the Sabbath keeps
me. Jesus said, "Come to me, all who
labor and are heavy laden, and I will
give you rest. Take my yoke upon you and
learn from me, for I am gentle and lowly
in heart, and you will find rest for
your souls, for my yoke is easy, and my
burden is light." Jesus Christ is God's
Sabbath. He is the eternal Sabbath. When
we come to him, we cease from our works.
When we come to him, we experience
eternal rest. It is not a rest that
comes once a week. It is a rest that
begins at regeneration and continues
until we are either with the Lord in our
post-mortem existence or when the Lord
returns. Jesus Christ is the end point
of the Sabbath. He is truly the Sabbath
itself who gives eternal rest.
Colossians 2:16-17, the apostle warns
the church against those who would pass
judgment on them in questions of food,
in questions of drink, or with regard to
a festival or a new moon or a Sabbath.
These are a shadow of the things to
come, but the substance or the body
belongs to Christ. Now, many Seventh
Adventists would argue that the Sabbath
here refers to the ceremonial Sabbaths.
But as I will argue in this debate, the
Sabbath is part of a unit called the
law. The law of God is not broken into
pieces. There is one unit that has
ceremonial, moral, and civil aspects to
it. If you notice the language here,
what Paul is using here is a familiar
pattern that we find in the Old
Testament prophets where he discusses
the annual festivals, the monthly
festivals, and the weekly festival
called the Sabbath. Leviticus 23 lists
the Sabbath as one of the weekly
festivals of the Lord. And so Paul goes
from the annual down to the monthly to
the weekly. And notice how he calls the
feast days, the new moons, and the
Sabbath a shadow of things to come. We
also find in Romans 14:4-6 there was a
dispute about what days to keep. The
Apostle Paul argued that some people
esteem one day is better than another
while another esteems all days alike.
That's me. Each one should be fully
convinced in his own mind. The one who
observes the day observes it in honor of
the Lord. Notice the Apostle Paul does
not designate which day he's referring
to. This would have been a perfect time
for him to say the one who observes the
seventh day or the first day, but he
doesn't. He simply says, "The one who
observes the day observes it to the
Lord." Notice that Sabbath is not
obligatory on Christians. In the Council
of Jerusalem, they rule that while the
Gentiles should observe certain rules
that that the apostles ordained, the
command to keep the Sabbath is not
mentioned. Nine out of the ten
commandments are repeated and enforced
in the New Testament except the fourth
commandment to observe the Sabbath. In
Mark 7:es
21-22, Jesus lists 13 sins. And yet, not
one of them mentions the breaking of the
Sabbath as one of those sins. When we
look at Romans
1:29-32, there are 20 sins that are
listed there by the apostle. And not one
of them is Sabbath breaking. 1
Corinthians 6:9-10, Paul mentions 10
sins that are listed that bar us from
the kingdom of God, and Sabbath breaking
is not one of them. Galatians
5:19-21 lists 15 sins that are given and
Sabbath breaking again is not among
them. 2 Timothy 3:1-4 there's a list of
18 sins that are mentioned by the
Apostle Paul. But not once a Sabbath
breaking mentioned the book of
Revelation 28:8 and
22:15. A total of 13 sins are mentioned.
And again, Sabbath breaking is not
mentioned among those sins. In fact, one
minute remaining. In fact, none of the
nations in the Old Testament are ever
condemned for breaking the Sabbath.
They're condemned for uh murder. They're
condemned for abuse. They're condemned
for uh rejecting God and and they're
condemned for blasphemy, but they're
never condemned for breaking the
Sabbath. And that's because the Sabbath
was unique to Israel as the sign of the
Mosaic covenant. And so, the Christian
is under the law of Christ. Paul
mentions the law of Christ. The law of
Christ is not to be confused with the
law of Moses, which is also the law of
the Lord. They're not separate. They're
not two different laws as Ellen White
taught and the Seventh Day Adventists
teach today. They are a unit. And Paul
also mentions the law of Christ in other
places in the New Testament. And what is
the law of Christ? The law of Christ is
all the commandments that Christ and the
apostles have given to the new covenant
community. That is the new covenant
church. The Sabbath has served its
purpose and Christ has brought it in
himself.
All right,
Tony, thank you so much for your opening
statement,
sir. All right, we will now be
transitioning
folks to the five minute rebuttal
period. We will begin Jose with you and
your time will begin sir when you begin
speaking.
All right. So, we only got five minutes,
so I'm not going to be able to address
everything. I think the idea of the
evenings uh and mornings concept, I
think we're getting into a little bit of
presumption and isogesis when we're
trying to sit there and state the reason
it's not there when the Bible doesn't
give you a reason evening and mornings
is not there. So, we're kind of adding
something into that. Respectfully, I
would say Exodus 16 to say that it was
first mentioned Shabbat in Exodus 16.
Well, I could say in Exodus 20, a whole
bunch of those laws were first
mentioned. You don't find a lot of
commands in Genesis mentioning, you
know, uh, you will have no other gods
before you. They're implied when you
read Genesis. And so, I'm not sure
that's a very good argument. As for
Nehemiah 9 and 13-14, making known the
Sabbaths, let me just say the word there
is to reveal or to declare
uh, as an, you know, to the people. And
so this declaration to a nation that
came out of Egypt and they had a lot to
learn. I mean, if you read the Torah,
you find that they had struggles with
idolatry, other gods, a whole bunch of
issues. So God had to establish things
that were probably passed upon patriarch
to patriarch originally. Um, and yes,
that is kind of uh an explanation based
on context. and Deuteronomy 5, he
mentions that the covenant was not made
with the fathers. It was made with
Israel. Well, the question that I'm
going to ask eventually here is listen,
if that's the truth, the new covenant
was also made with Israel. So, we're
going to make that same application,
then Jesus didn't die for
Gentiles. He died for just Israel. But I
don't think we're going to state that.
All right. as far as uh Jeremiah not be
like uh you know when we talk about uh
the law um not being or the new covenant
not being like the old covenant. Let me
just state to that. I mean Jeremiah
tells you why the issue wasn't God. The
issue was the people of God which is why
the new covenant speaks about the hearts
and the minds. Because God's people were
stubborn and we haven't changed. Israel
was stubborn and we are too. We're
always looking for ways to not do what
God asks us to do. And so, ah, I don't
know about that one either. Now, Jesus
the real Sabbath. I'd like my opponent
to show us where in the Bible does it
say that Jesus is the Sabbath. Now, I
love the idea that Jesus is my ultimate
rest. Yes, I want to come to him to take
that load off of me. And I do believe
the Sabbath is a weekly reminder of a
daily rest I have with him and I will
eventually have in eternity. That's a
beautiful thing. As for Colossians
2:16-17, I'm just going to say context,
y'all. I mean, all in that chapter, he's
there talking about traditions of men,
philosophies, ideologies. He's not
sitting there talking about the law. But
do I believe that it mentions the
Sabbath? Yes. But I do believe that that
mention of the Sabbath is not speaking
of biblical Sabbathkeeping as far as the
basic resting on the Sabbath day. But in
connection to not just the ceremonial
ritual cultic laws involved with
sacrifices, drink offerings and all
those things, but also the tradition of
the rabbis. We need to remember when
Jesus was constantly criticized, you
know, we try to bring up, oh, he had
tension with the Sabbath. Did he have
tension with breaking the Sabbath, his
law, or did he have tension with
breaking the rabbis interpretations? Uh,
one minute remaining. Romans 14. Let me
just say this, uh, opinion, idea. Romans
14:1 starts with we're not, we're
transitioning into doubtful things,
disputable things. Romans already
established the law is not disputable.
So to then put Sabbath into the day
seems a little isogetical. I would also
say that the word alike is added. It's
not in the Greek. I would reread that
verse without that. Acts 15, I would
just say Moses is preached. That said,
when they give him the few little
regulations they want him to follow, I
would say there's a lot of arguments
from silence in this presentation. I
mean, just to say that 1 Corinthians 6,
Galatians 5, 2 Timothy 3 doesn't mention
the Sabbath. Guys, the Jews weren't busy
breaking the Sabbath. That was not
Jesus's concern with them. That's it for
now.
Perfect timing once again, Jose. Thank
you for that. Tony, your five minute
rebuttal period will begin when you
begin speaking, sir.
Okay. Thank you very much. Um, let me
just say from the outset that I think
Jose is confusing. The the law, the law
of God, the law of Moses is 613
commandments. They're not broken into
ceremonial laws, moral laws, civil laws,
and so forth. It is the law. It is a
unit. Jesus gave over 400 commandments
in the New Testament. Now when we go
through what uh Jose was saying there,
he seems to forget that each of these
covenants bear signs. They have signs.
The sign of the Abraham covenant was
circumcision. The sign of noa covenant
was the rainbow. The sign of the Mosaic
covenant was the Sabbath. The sign of
the new covenant is the cup of the Lord
that we share in the Lord's table. Now,
you will also notice that during his
presentation, he says the law doesn't
change, but it does. Uh, in Hebrews
7:12, we're even told about how the
Levitical priesthood had to change
because there's a new priesthood. That
is the priesthood of Melzdc that only
Jesus Christ has. Now, that doesn't
mean, oh, it's just a ceremonial law.
The law is a unit. You cannot break it
into pieces. No Jew would ever think
that the law was made up of, well, 50%
is ceremonial, 20% is moral. Not at all.
The Bible never treats the law that way.
And to suggest that the law of God and
the law of Moses are two different
things violates scripture. Now, notice
that Jose said that a lot of what I
said, he says, "Well, there's arguments
from silence." Well, isn't it
interesting that in all of the sin lists
that Paul mentions and that Jesus
mentions and that the book of Revelation
mentions, don't you think it's very odd
that there is nothing said about
breaking the Sabbath? It talks about
adultery, blasphemy, idolatry,
disrespecting parents, murder, stealing.
In fact, it mentions all nine that nine
of the ten commandments that we find on
the tablets. But there's one commandment
that seems to be conspicuously missing,
and that is the Sabbath commandment. And
the reason for that is the Sabbath
commandment was part of the Mosaic
covenant. The Mosaic covenant has come
to an end in Christ. And therefore,
since the Mosaic covenant has ended, we
are now under a new covenant with a
better priesthood, a better a better
law, a better mediator, better promises,
a better sacrifice, and so on and so
forth. Now, it's interesting that Hosea
says, well, I don't see nor does the
Bible say Jesus is my Sabbath. Well, in
John, in Matthew 11 at verses 28 to30,
right after he said, I am the one. Come
to me all of you who are tired and heavy
laden, and I will give you rest.
Immediately following those words, he
goes through the field with his
disciples and they're plucking wheat and
the Pharisees are accusing them of
breaking the Sabbath. Isn't it
interesting that immediately after Jesus
said, "Come to me and rest. I will give
you rest." The very next thing he does
is he goes into the fields on the
Sabbath and gets into this conversation
about the Sabbath. The Sabbath is about
Jesus. Everything in the law of Moses,
in the prophets, in the Psalms, Luke
24:44, is about me. The tabernacle is
about Christ. The sacrifices are about
Christ. The the the the the priesthood
is about Christ. The the royal house of
David is about Christ. It is the Old
Testament is crystalentric. It's crisis
telic. It's about the Messiah who is
king, prophet, and priest. And so he is
the ark of the covenant. He is the
Sabbath. He is our Passover lamb. He is
the tabernacle in which God dwells in
bodily form. The word became flesh. and
he tabernacled amongst us. And then to
say that Colossians 2:16, well, it's
talking about all this weird stuff, but
Paul mentions circumcision in Colossians
2:12. That's Jewish. Circumcision was
demanded by the Judaizers. And then to
say that in in Genesis 26:5, that
Abraham obeyed God's precepts and his
laws and so forth. That's a Jesus to
suggest that Abraham knew the sonatic
covenant. Well, if Jose is going to
follow that, then he should observe
circumcision because Abraham observed
circumcision before the law of Moses.
Abraham observed burnt sacrifices and
offering. And yet, I don't think one
minute remaining. I don't think Jose or
any Seventh Adventist would say that
they're following Abraham's example by
by following circumcision and uh and
sacrifices and so forth. And then even
Romans 14, disputable matters. Exactly.
Exactly. What are the disputable
matters? the matters about food and
days. And so that's what we're debating
here today. We're talking about is the
Sabbath, the seventh day Sabbath,
relevant to the Christian. And Paul
says, look, don't divide over these
things. If you observe the day, you
observe it to the Lord. He's not saying,
"Come on, guys. You know the fourth
commandment, you ought to obey the
Sabbath." He doesn't do that. And you'll
notice that Paul is conspicuously silent
about the Gentiles observing the Sabbath
law. And so what we're hearing here
today, and I say this with all due
respect, is that Jose is reading this
through the lenses of LG. White and he's
reading this through an Adventist
paradigm. So if you look at the context
of Colossians 2, Romans 14, time 5, you
will know that Christians are not
obligated to keep the seventh day
Sabbath. Thank you.
All right, Tony, thank you for your
rebuttal there. We are now going to
transition into our
crossexamination. I want to remind
everybody that this will be
four 20 minute
intervals where each interlocator will
have two of those 20-minut periods. We
will begin with the negative side and it
will end with the affirmative side
before we transition into our closings.
So gentlemen, with that
said, Tony, you will be starting. Your
time will begin. Your first interval of
20 minutes will begin for you to begin
your questioning, sir, when you begin
speaking. Okay. I'm just setting up my
clock here. All good. All right. Okay.
So, um, Jose,
um, in in the Old
Testament, where does the word Shabbat
first appear?
I agree.
I'm sorry. The word Shabbat's
Exodus 16. Okay. So, um why don't we uh
do we find Abraham uh Isaac, Jacob? Do
we find Enoch who walked with God and
God took him? Um is there any record of
the patriarchs observing the Sabbath
day? No, there is no record of the
patriarchs uh uh the Why is that?
Well, I mean the Bible's silent on it. I
dare not speak on something that the
Bible doesn't mind trying to explain. I
mean, the Bible is silent on them
keeping a lot of the other commandments
that are the Jews came up with the whole
nohide spec because they had to come up
with something there outside of just
like not killing or not murdering or any
such matter like that. you know, we
don't see talking about blasphemy and
and a bunch of these other things.
That's also not there. But I do believe
that Abraham obeyed that and kept to one
God and didn't blaspheme God and and and
all etc etc. Do you believe what Paul
says in Romans 1 that the moral uh the
moral aspects of God's law are in the
hearts of all human beings?
Romans 1 that the moral aspects of all
God's law are in the heart in the
conscience the human conscience.
Uh so I believe that God use So you're
talking about Romans chapter 2 then
right? Uh I'm talking about chapter one
where he talks about that they who do
not have the law have it written in
their hearts in their conscience.
Yeah. Yeah. So
in in in in the book of Romans when it
talks about that very aspect of the law
being in in the hearts um or or
conscience bearing witness to them which
actually is Romans chapter 2. Um I I
will state that uh that aspect of that
is not referring to literally oh every
human being automatically has God's law
or knows. Yeah, we have a certain
understanding of right and wrong. And I
believe the Holy Spirit has given that
to us. But the entire revelation of
God's law, I don't think that's what he
I'm not talking about the entire
revelation. I'm talking about what's
known as common common uh common grace.
I'm talking about general revelation. So
So uh Cain knew when he killed Abel, he
knew that he he committed murder. He
knew that whoever would find him would
want to kill him. Is that true? Correct.
How did he know that murder was wrong?
Well, for one, God finds out, right? And
comes looking for him. I mean, that's
the first time we actually see that. And
obviously, it's defined as
sin. And the reality is that Paul makes
it clear in Romans chapter 7. I mean,
you you can't know sin unless there's a
law. So, what was what was the law in
the time of Cain?
I do believe that was the moral law as
we see written in the ten commandments.
Sure. So, so if the if the Sabbath is
part of the moral law, then why do we
not see Abraham and Isaac and Jacob and
Enoch and Adam and Joseph observing the
uh the Sabbath? Yeah. I mean, I that
question. Uh we don't see them doing a
lot of the other moral laws in the Ten
Commandments. And yet it's implied it's
implied by the fact that well in Genesis
obviously and this is written by Moses.
He's the one using Genesis as a teaching
tool. He starts with Genesis 2 that God
declared the seventh day holy. All
right? And so by him declaring that that
becomes just a given. I think if you
were a Jew reading uh
Genesis 2:es 1-3, you were going to read
that and go, "Okay, here we go. We've
got God establishing the Sabbath day
before sin, before creation." I think
this concept uh that all of a sudden,
well, God didn't give it as a command,
so what's going on there? I think that's
a relatively Christian uh traditional
argument. But yet uh you just admitted
earlier that there's no mention of the
Sabbath in Genesis and that the first
time the word Sabbath appears is in
Exodus uh in the context of God um
entering into a covenant with Israel.
Yeah. Yeah. And and I think so I think I
think it's pretty reasonable to
understand that when Israel is in Egypt
uh they had some serious corruption
happened to them. I mean, when they got
out of Egypt, we see all the corruption
that was amongst them as a people. I
mean, everything from idols to
worshiping multiple gods, doing things
that we would never say Abraham did. All
right? Um, and so God is re-educating
them as to who he is, who he aims to be,
what he's done for them. You know, when
he introduces Exodus 20, he says, "I am
the Lord your God that brought I mean,
they didn't know who he was." Well, of
course, they knew who he was, but I I do
believe that you see evidence that Egypt
had messed them up. Well, of course. I
don't think anyone has ever doubted
that. So, so we we have affirmed then
that the Sabbath, the word Shabbat
appears for the first time in Exodus 16.
Correct. And then and then in in um
Deuteronomy 5 um and Exodus 34, we're
told that the covenant that God made at
Sinai was the ten commandments. Do you
agree with that? Sure. And when he says
that he did not make this covenant with
the fathers, but with us who are here
today, do you see that that that
covenant that God made with Moses is not
the same covenant that he made with
Abraham?
Well, I mean, I would say when I'm
interpreting that that we're actually
seeing that as not given in the same
way. I mean, obviously Moses did not
receive tablets of stone with the ring,
the written commandments with the finger
of God. He didn't get that. And so, that
doesn't mean that those laws were not
transferred or given in any form of
verbal fashion. And hence why I
mentioned Genesis that it says he obeyed
the voice of God and these things got
passed along. And so when it says, oh,
it wasn't made uh with the fathers in
that way, I would also say uh this is
why I don't just look at that as simply
just the ten commandments because
obviously I don't believe Abraham
celebrated Passover. Not in that way.
Passover directly states that it's
related to coming out of Egypt. The
Sabbath is pointed back, Moses points it
back to creation, not something you
Israel, but Passover, tabernacles, many
of those were very unique to the
experience of Israel. The Sabbath has a
little more his historical uh background
to it. Now you know that in Deuteronomy
5 in the repetition of the ten
commandments, Exodus 20 says that you
are to keep the Sabbath, for in six days
the Lord made heaven and earth. But in
Deuteronomy 5, you will notice that
they're to keep the Sabbath because they
were once slaves in the land of Egypt.
So do you notice in Deuteronomy 5, the
language there is pointing to the
redemption of the people from bondage
and slavery. So the Sabbath in Exodus 20
with Israel reminds them of God as
creator and in Deuteronomy 5, it reminds
them of God as redeemer. Would you agree
with that assessment?
Uh if you find me a little bit to think
in Exodus 20, the context that Moses
gives is God directly stating his
commandments written with his finger.
When you get to Deuteronomy 5, this is
40 years later. This is a new generation
getting ready to enter the promised
land. They were probably kids when they
got out of Egypt. Moses is
not re giving them the tablets. He is
restating the law. And therefore, when
you see him restating the law, he kind
of gives some extra little what I would
call commentary to that very
commandment. And so I don't believe that
God wrote in his finger two different
kinds of Sabbath commandment. He gave
them one, the fourth commandment on
tablets of stone. And then Moses in
verbalizing that to a new
generation adds an extra uh teaching
tool to them with the Sabbath which I
think is really awesome and that is what
you said their redemption. Moses is an
inspired writer that Moses when he wrote
he wrote under the inspiration of the
Holy Spirit. Sure. But we got added
context of what's happening
again 20. He is recording what God wrote
with his finger in
Deuter. He's talking. He is doing a a
homaly or whatever you want to call it.
He's reviewing history with the
Israelites. And yes, I do believe that
also was from the Holy Spirit, of
course. Yeah. Yeah. So, do you believe
uh Jose that that you need to keep the
Sabbath to be saved?
No.
So if a Christian does not keep the
Sabbath, will he be condemned?
So what my presentation to make it clear
is just like any other of the ten
commandments. If I were to ask somebody,
are you going to be lost if you don't
commit
adultery? Or are you lost if you commit
adultery? I mean, we are saved by grace
through faith alone. That's where it's
at. But what I'm saying is saved
Christians obey God's law. And so I
would say if you're breaking, if you're
saying you're saved and you're out there
sleeping with somebody's wife that's not
your own, I would start to wonder, are
you really that person that you claim to
be? I think we'd all agree with that.
Yeah, I have I have no doubt about that.
But you would agree that committing
adultery is always wrong. Is that
correct?
Yeah. Along with the ten commandments.
Yes. Well, murdering someone is always
wrong. Yes. Um are there exceptions
where the Sabbath can be broken, where
it's not a sin?
If you're referring to Jesus's
discussion of that with the scribes and
the Pharisees, I would dare to say if
you're reading that contextually,
exegetically, he's not arguing them
about breaking the Sabbath the way he
originally gave it with his own finger.
He's talking about the many traditions
and customs that came from post
Babylonian Judaism that in their fear of
having broken the Sabbath, being taken
exile, they put all these extra rules
and regulations that are not part of the
Mosaic law, God's law. They got nothing
to do with that. So when they come to
Jesus, hey, you guys are uh what are you
doing? Grabbing, you know, wheat and
Yeah, it I understand that, Jose. I
understand that. I understand that. What
I'm saying is, are there cases where you
can break the Sabbath in order to save
life?
But I don't believe that's breaking the
Sabbath. Okay. Okay. So, if a surgeon
has to work and do uh emergency heart
surgery on someone on the Sabbath,
that's work. He's working. He has to
open your chest. He's got to go in
there. Got to do some work. So that is
technically working, right? But said,
and notice how he said it, it is lawful
to do good on the Sabbath after he
healed someone by working by working by
working to save life, even the life of a
lamb. But that's the Sabbath. Okay. So
that's my point. So, it's always wrong
to commit adultery seven days a week.
You can It's wrong to commit adultery.
It's It's wrong to commit murder seven
days a week. The Sabbath can only be
broken once a week. And but there are
exceptions in that the Sabbath, you can
work on the Sabbath if it is to save
life. And so the the the Sabbath in that
case is not on an equal standing with
the other commandments because you can
sin and commit adultery seven days a
week, but you can't break the Sabbath
seven days a week. You see what I'm
saying? The Sabbath is that one
commandment that you can actually
trespass in order to save life. Again, I
would highly disagree with you. It is
not a trespass of the law to save a
life. Jesus said it was lawful. I agree.
You're ising that and saying that that's
a breaking when our savior and lord said
it is not breaking. The Jews saw it as
breaking the Sabbath. Jesus made it
clear when I gave the law because he's
the lawgiver. He made it clear that is
not breaking the Sabbath. And so I, you
know, I I think that you're kind of
taking that a little bit too far. And I
would also say to make the statement
that um well uh how did you put it? Uh
the Sabbath can only be broken once a
week. Well, it's about a it's a it's a
day that God made holy out of the seven
days, right? So, let's think about Jesus
saying in Matthew 12 that the priests
profane the Sabbath and they are not
held guilty. And he talks about the the
the priests profane the Sabbath by
working in the tabernacle because you
got to take animals, slit their throats,
you got to put them on the altar. That
involves work. Sure. And so the Lord
Jesus Christ, who is the Lord of the
Sabbath, when he's doing uh divine
service on the Sabbath, even though it's
work, is completely permissible. That's
right. And permissible means it's not
breaking and sinning the Sabbath, but
it's working. It
is. But making clear, that is not the
kind of work that the Sabbath is talking
about. He's making that clear. He's not
talking about spiritual work, healing,
emergencies to help people. He had to
clarify that the scribes and Pharisees.
He's still trying to clarify it for us
today in my opinion. But when when I'm
looking the reality is to keep saying
that in a yes the the word that he uses
profane I believe Jesus is making a
point obviously to the scribes and
Pharisees and what he's telling them is
listen you want to criticize me but look
at what the scri you know there is
permissible work to be done on on so so
Jose where where in the new testament do
we have a command to the church to keep
the seventh day Sabbath. We're in the
new Is there a command to observe the
seventh day Sabbath? There is not. Okay.
Is there a command to not murder in the
New Testament?
Sure. It talks about not murdering. So,
not murdering uh not to commit idolatry,
not to blaspheme, honor your father and
your mother, do do not bear false
witness, do not covet. But yet the
commandment to keep the Sabbath is
conspicuously absent. Why is that?
Well, honestly, when I think about that,
I mean, why is that? I don't see that
the Jews were busy breaking the Sabbath
like that. In fact,
the the the four gospels, they were
overemphasizing things on the Sabbath
that God had not really told them to
overemphasize. And so Jesus is having to
hey remind them of what the true meaning
of the Sabbath really is all about the
way he originally gave. We we discussed
that already Jose but but you would
agree with me that there is no command
in the new covenant. We do have nine of
those ten commandments ratified and
repeated but there is no command in the
new testament for Christians to keep the
Sabbath. the seventh seventh day Sabbath
already answered there is not a command
but what I'm saying is the teachings on
the Sabbath are still there is no
there's no statement in the New
Testament saying that we do not we
should not keep the Sabbath day holy
that's not there either now we'll talk
about Colossians 2 but it's not there's
no command do not keep the Sabbath day
you don't have to do that anymore that's
actually never out of Jes Jesus's mouth.
Never once does Jesus say, "Hey, when I
die and I come back to life, you guys
aren't going to have to worry about the
Sabbath day anymore in any of his
teachings on the Sabbath." So, so when
when the the the scriptures speak about
the the law that Christ is the end of
the law to all who believe. Yeah. And
that um in Christ um the the annual
feasts, the new moon festivals, the the
Sabbath were all a shadow of that which
is to come and that Christ is the
reality. Um do you believe that Christ
is the end of the law to all those who
believe? Yeah. So, as you know and
you've said in your own writings, I mean
that that word end points towards uh it
could be goal uh or purpose of the law.
And yes, I mean ultimately the law
doesn't save you. Jesus does. And so the
law points me to my savior. Facts always
does. Identifying sin one minute
problem. Okay. So, with the time I have,
do you believe the law of God and the
law of Moses is the same?
Well, I would say that the law of God is
a
unit. I would agree with you, but its
application, we do see differences along
the way. Hence why you brought up the
ceremonial and the civil aspects of that
law. But is the law is the law of the
Lord and the law of Moses the same thing
in your thinking or Adventist thinking?
So the law of Moses the law of God. So
some 7th day Adventists might argue the
concept that the law of Moses is
referring to the ceremonial laws as that
aspect of it all. And I I would simply
just say to that when you're looking at
the Ten Commandments versus what Moses
wrote down, that is all Torah. That's
all Torah. And yet notice the laws that
Moses wrote down are put on time.
Okay, I'll pick it up in the next uh
cross exam.
All right, gentlemen. Thank you for the
lively back and forth. We will now
rotate. Jose, your first 20 minute
cross-examination period for you to ask
questions and control the time with Tony
will begin when you begin speaking, sir.
All right. First of all, I appreciate uh
doing this with you, Dr. Costa. This is
really having a good time. I hope
everybody else is. Um and so I want to
start with uh a question. Uh where does
the Bible say Jesus is our Sabbath? Now,
I want to preface that with I can find
texts that say Jesus is our Passover. 1
Corinthians 5, Jesus is the lamb. John
1, Jesus is our high priest. Hebrews
chapter 4. I mean, we can go down the
line where the Bible clearly uses these
words to say this Jesus. So, where do
you see the Bible literally saying Jesus
is our Shabbat?
Well, it doesn't literally say that
Jesus is our Shabbat, but it does use
the technical language of Sabbath. So
for example in Matthew 11 at the end of
Matthew 11:28-30 Jesus says come to me
all of you who are heavy laden and tired
and I will give you rest and learn of me
for my yoke is easy and I'm humble and
meek in spirit and so forth. So
immediately after making that statement,
Jesus goes into the fields in chapter 12
of Matthew. Uh he goes immediately into
the fields and it's the Sabbath and he
he teaches a lesson there on the
Sabbath. And so the technical language
here and the context because context is
king here. The context of Matthew
11:28-30 and 12 of course is linked to
the Sabbath. And so just the same way
the apostle John in John 1:14, John does
not call uh Jesus uh he doesn't say
Jesus is the feast of tabernacles or a
booth but he says in John 1:14 that the
word became flesh and he tabernacled
amongst us or pinched his tent as the
Greek says skelo. So there in John 1:14
you clearly see Jesus uh fulfilling uh
the feast of tabernacles. You see him in
John 10:22 at the feast of dedication in
Jerusalem on the feast of Hanukkah. Uh
he is definitely uh our Passover lamb.
Um he is also the ark even though he's
not called the ark of the covenant. Uh
the ark represents him because he holds
the law of God within himself. He has
the mana. He's the bread of life. Um the
the rod of Aaron representing the cross
and the resurrection and so forth. So
I'm taking the cue from Jesus himself in
ma in Luke
24:44. He opened their eyes to
understand the scriptures and it says
everything written of me in the law of
Moses and the prophets and the psalms
must be fulfilled. And so when I read
the Old Testament, Jesus tells me to
read it through his eyes. It's
christoologgical. And so even though
Jesus doesn't use the words I'm I'm the
Sabbath, the language of rest, being
tired and being given rest immediately
following a um a paricopy uh dealing
with the Sabbath, I think clearly shows
that association. So, so I don't have a
problem with the concept of him being
our ultimate rest. That is biblical.
That is clear. That is in scripture that
in Jesus we can find rest. But I think
the crux that I'm asking of the argument
is even if it revolves that next Matthew
12 goes into a Sabbath situation
obviously there's a connection between
Sabbath and rest. I don't disagree with
that but you are stating that there is
no direct. So when you mention that
Jesus is the mercy seat that's directly
stated in the book of Hebrews he and
well actually I rather I should say in
in first John when it talks about him
being our propitiation right that's our
mercy seat and and John and Romans
chapter 3 I think it is that really uses
that term um and so when we're talking
about those things they directly point
to that. So my question is you do not
see and you've made that clear at the
beginning. You do not see a direct
statement that says Jesus is our
Sabbath. It says Jesus is our rest.
Okay. Okay. Let let me Okay. So I do I
do a lot of evangelism with Muslims uh
Jose and one of the things I hear them
say is show me in the Bible where Jesus
said in these exact words, I am God
worship me.
So he doesn't have to say in those exact
words, I am God, worship me. He he
showed it by his work and by identifying
himself as the I am and so forth. What
I'm pointing out here is that Matthew
11:28-30 Jesus speaks about himself as
the giver of rest of eternal rest. And
this follows a paricopy on the Sabbath.
In Hebrews 4, the author of Hebrews goes
further and tells us that those who have
come to Christ have entered into his
rest. And he talks about that word
sabatismos there in Hebrews in Hebrews
4. He speaks there's a Sabbath rest to
the people of God. And that Sabbath rest
is not the seventh day. That Sabbath
rest is today. If you hear his voice
then and do not uh harden your hearts
like the Israelites did in the
wilderness, you will enter his rest. And
Hebrews, the author of Hebrews tells us
that Christian believers have already
entered into that rest. And the reason
why they've entered into that rest is
because they have come to Christ. So Dr.
Costa, let me ask you this. You believe
that the Hebrews 4 by mentioning that
rest that is today. You believe that by
saying that that the apostle well if
this is Pauline theology but whoever
wrote that for the sake of this right uh
whoever wrote that by saying that we
have a rest today you see there in
Hebrews 4 that that's automatically an
argument against Sabbathkeeping
yes because it's not it's it's an
argument against seventh day uh even in
my opinion not just seventh day but
first
keeping um the the Sabbath rest there is
Christ and that's why the author of
Hebrews says today this day if you hear
his voice you can enter that rest and so
the gospel message is this today
whoever's listening you're a 7th
Adventist whatever you are if you don't
know Christ you can enter his rest today
is that day you know Paul says today of
salvation. Yeah. Go ahead. Agree that
today is the you want to accept Christ.
We don't wait till Sabbath to accept
Jesus. Do it today,
etc. I'm with you 100%. But my question
still stands. When I look exeetically at
Hebrews 4, I'm not seeing an argument
for or against the fourth commandment.
To me, when I'm looking at Hebrews 4,
I'm seeing that's that's not even what
he's referring to. He's talking about an
ultimate rest. My question to you would
be, is it impossible that this text uses
because it does mention uh Genesis
chapter 2, right? It mentions God.
Does mention that. So, yes, it does.
Could it be possible that this can be
interpreted as well as saying that the
Sabbath
commandment is a weekly reminder of the
ultimate rest that I can have with
Christ today? Is that an impossible
interpretation? I would say it is
because if you look at the context,
remember Genesis 2 does not mention the
Sabbath. It mentions rest that God rest
them. And then it says again in the
passage and I was referring to Psalm 96
above he says they shall not enter my
rest. That's the point of contact. The
point of contact is the rest not the
Sabbath day. And then he says verse X
there remains for some to enter that
rest. And since those who firmly
formerly had the good news or gospel
proclaimed to them did not go in because
of their disobedience, God has set a
certain day. Notice this, calling it
today, not the Sabbath, not Sunday, not
Monday. And this he did when a long time
a long time later he spoke through David
as in the passage already quoted. And
there's that passage today if you hear
his voice. So the author is clearly
telling us, Jose, that he's talking
about a day that is today, not the
seventh day, not the first day. Yeah. So
you you just finished saying that the
term Sabbath is not there in Hebrews 4.
The argument is about rest, not thus for
commandment. My my point is that the
word sabatismos in Greek means a rest.
It it refers to a Sabbath rest just like
I can take a Sabbath from work or I take
a sabbatical that means a rest period.
It doesn't mean I'm going to take off
every Saturday. It means if I go on
sabbatical, that means I'm on I'm I'm
off work for whatever to write a book,
whatever it may be. But the context of
Hebrews 4, remember Jose, Hebrews is
about Jesus being better than the
angels, better than Moses, better than
Aaron, better priesthood, um better
promises, better mediator, and the
Sabbath points to him. And the whole
point of Hebrews is if you come to
Christ, you have ceased from your works.
You have entered his rest. And I can
tell you this, Jose, I have entered his
rest and I'm enjoying his rest. Amen.
And and that is my hope that all that
come to Christ that they will know this
true rest in him. So I don't see Hebrews
4 supporting a seventh day Sabbath.
Yeah. I think I think there is I don't
see Hebrews 4 supporting a seventh day
Sabbath either, but I don't see it going
against the seventh day Sabbath either.
It's simply telling you that the
ultimate rest you have is in Christ.
Correct. It's Christ. It's Christ in
Christ alone. And and let me make can I
just quickly, Jose, just to clarify
things because I know you're asking the
questions and that is based on on Romans
14 uh uh 1-6. Um, I have no problem if
if a if a Christian believer I know some
Christian believers um who are
evangelical who who keep the Sabbath
day. I have no issue with that because
I'm told in Romans 4 not to pass
judgment on those uh who observe this
day of the week or that day. I'm not to
pass judgment on what they eat. And and
so I'm not saying you can most
definitely not you should never do that.
I believe that it's a gray area and
that's where you and I would disagree.
Um but I but I certainly in the spirit
of Romans 14 would not pass judgment on
someone someone if they wish to keep the
seventh day. Just likewise I hope that
people don't pass judgment on those who
keep the first day. But that again is
where our paths will will differ. And of
course Ellen White believed that Sunday
keepers would eventually receive the
mark of the beast. And so uh that's a
that's an area where where the twain
shall never meet.
Yeah. Well, I I I just want to mention
we're not really arguing what Ellen
White said and we're not arguing
but I am just saying that when it comes
to the Sabbath or Sunday the 7th day
Adventist there is no allowance for
Sunday worship what this debate is
about. So I kind of find correct there
we that's not what we're discussing. Now
now I want to ask you a question. What
law is Hebrews chapter 8 referring to in
your mind? Then the new law, the new
covenant.
So you believe now he you agree that
Hebrews chapter 8 is citing Jeremiah 31,
right? Right. Absolutely. Okay. Now, do
you see a statement there in Jeremiah 31
or Hebrews 8 that says new law?
uh a new covenant would imply that if
there's a new the word the word covenant
is the same word we get the word
testament from right abit in Hebrew di
in in in Greek so if you have a new
covenant then you have a new law uh
hebrews 7 is very clear that with the
death of Christ there came a change in
the law so that the the priesthood of
Levitic of of Levi is no longer longer
operative that um we have a new priest
based on better promises and this new
priest is a priest after the order of
Melzdc. Well, under the Mosaic law,
Jesus could not be a priest because in
order to be a priest, you had to be from
the tribe of Levi. But Jesus comes from
the tribe of Judah. And Moses said
nothing about priesthood in reference to
Judah as Hebrews tells us. So with the
coming of the new covenant, you have a
new priesthood. You have a new mediator,
a better mediator. And so as Hebrews
says, with a change in the priesthood,
this necessitates a change in the law.
And that's what the Greek literally
says, a change. But I'm coming back.
Does Heb 8 say that there is a change in
the law? There is a change in the law in
that it will not be like that of Horeb.
this law, this covenant will involve God
writing his law on the hearts of his
people. Yeah. So, and putting his words
in their mind. So, let me ask you a
followup on that. Sure. 8 vers uh 8 and
N. Let's let's have this
conversation. When the Bible talks about
that he is going to make a
covenant with their fathers, right? uh
not according to the covenant rather
that he made with their fathers but he's
going to make a new one right does it
not state and I want to see what you
understand about this why did God and
and I believe it's here in verse 9 why
did God state that a new covenant was
necessary
it was necessary because the people he
found fault with them as you see in
verse eight there um and because the
people broke broke the covenant of
Horeb. They broke that covenant. Um, and
notice there in verse 9, it will not be
like the covenant I made with their
ancestors when I took them by the hand
to lead them out of Egypt because they
did not remain faithful to my covenant.
Well, that covenant was the Mosaic law
was the ten commandments that he gave on
Mount Si. And so says, I turned away
from them. And so this necessitates a
new a new covenant because a covenant is
the covenant of God with Israel is like
a marriage. He married them. That was a
marriage covenant on Mount Si. Totally
agree. But let me let me ask this as
followup here. The issue as you just
stated isn't God. It's the people. Is it
not? The people. Well, the covenant is a
two-way party. Right.
The Abrahamic covenant was not the
Abrahamic covenant was unilateral. It
was between it was God. That's why the
Abrahamic covenant is greater than the
Mosaic covenant based on the promises.
Um but in in the Mosaic covenant that
was a bilateral agreement because in
Exodus 19, remember what the Lord says,
if you obey my words, if the conditional
you keep my commandments, then you shall
be unto me a kingdom of priests. And so
they agreed whatever the Lord says we
shall do. So they agreed. So it was a
bilateral uh covenant. Uh Jose, that's
very important. It was bilateral. Saying
bilateral, but with Abraham was
unilateral. So what you're trying is
that Abraham did not have to believe God
in order for that covenant to be
fulfilled. No. What it means is that God
would keep the terms of the covenant
with Abraham even if Abraham wouldn't
keep it. So, so that is unilateral and
that's why Paul says that the mo the law
of Moses, the law came 430 years after
Abraham. It cannot disanol the promises
made to Abraham. The Abrahamic covenant
is greater than the Mosaic covenant
because it is the foundation of the new
covenant. It is the foundation of the
Davidic covenant. So, so when God who is
the same, right,
covenants aren't going to contradict
each other. Would you agree?
Well, some covenants uh um some
covenants will supersede others.
So the new covenant is greater than the
old covenant because in the old covenant
you entered through
circumcision and in the old covenant it
was a national covenant. So Esau was
circumcised. He was in there and Ishmael
was circumcised and but none of them
were really chosen by God. I mean I mean
you you know the story that the majority
of Israelites died in the wilderness but
in the new covenant it's different. In
the new covenant, the Lord says, "They
shall all know me from the least of them
to the greatest." In other words, in the
new covenant, the only people in the new
covenant are those who know the Lord.
The old covenant, you could know the
Lord, but it was still a national
covenant. So, there's a there's a there
is a difference. And so, is better.
Yeah. There is. My question is you're
already saying one uh is super superior
the other. The question is I I hear a
little bit of an assumption in that
whereas whether the covenants are
superior or
complimentary from the perspective of
God. My question was would God create
new covenants that contradict old
covenants?
God makes new
covenants that complement the old
covenants but also supersede them. So
the new covenant is much greater than
the old covenant. Well
what it's not a contradiction. I mean
God God does not change in terms of his
essence. God is immutable. The the
assayity of God maintains that he's
immutable. But God does change his
methodology in revelation history. So in
the old covenant he dealt with Israel.
In the new covenant he deals with one
minute remaining. Got one minute. So let
me ask you this question as we continue.
I don't mean to interrupt. I try
but let me let me come in and ask you
this. Now we're talking about the law
and I may have to follow up with this
afterwards. Talking about the law, the
Torah, one thing that God gave Israel,
right? Mhm. But you're talking about the
possibilities of different applications
in that reality. And my question to you
is, do you notice any distinction
between what is written in the stone
tablets versus what Moses wrote? And may
I ask, where were those stone tablets
placed? And where was what Moses wrote
placed? Yeah. The the the tablets of the
law were placed in the ark of the
covenant. and that what Moses wrote was
on the side of of the ark. However, we
need to understand that the greatest
commandments in God's law do not come
from the ten commandments. The greatest
commandments, thou shalt love the Lord
thy God with all thy heart, mind, and
soul, and love your neighbor.
Deuteronomy 6:4 and Leviticus 19:8,
those supersede the ten commandments.
All right, gentlemen. Great exchange
once again. We will now reverse and Tony
you will have your final 20 minute
cross- examination. Your time will begin
when you start talking sir. Okay. So,
um, uh, uh, Jose, uh, if you can turn to
Luke chapter 2, Luke chapter
2, and if you look at
verses
22 to
24, you'll notice that it makes
reference there to the law of
Moses and the law of the Lord.
Um so when the time for the purification
of of rights required by the law of
Moses, Joseph Mary took him to Jerusalem
to present him to the Lord. As it is
written in the law of the Lord, every
firstborn male is to be consecrated to
the Lord and to offer a sacrifice in
keeping with what is said in the law of
the Lord, a pair of doves or two young
pigeons. Is the law of Moses and the law
of the Lord there being used
synonymously?
I believe so. Contextually. Yes. So the
law of Moses contextually is the law of
the Lord. Sure. And so these so these
laws here are not from the ten
commandments.
These laws are not from the ten
commandments. So I would say one of the
things that I would point out is that
this so again while I believe that I I I
can agree exegetically we're looking at
the Torah. It's one unit. But I think it
also needs to be understood though that
God himself made the distinction between
that written in stone that written by
Moses. Now why do I say that? The other
laws written by Moses, sacrifices, feast
days, all that stuff, even what you're
pointing out in Luke chapter 2, none of
that had any relevance unless we define
what sin is. if you don't know what sin
is. Because all of that was teaching you
what a savior is going to do, what the
Messiah would do, what Jesus would come
and do. And of course, you and I both
know the civil laws were the laws that
said, "Hey, if you do break one of these
commandments, what are the
consequences?" They're punitive in that
regards. So while you don't necessarily
see that God's law is sitting there
saying oh this is ceremonial this is uh
moral and this is that but when you
study law period laws have purposes and
even God himself made a distinction by
putting one in the ark of the covenant
and putting one to the side. One was the
standard by which everything else was
understood.
So, the law of Moses and the law of the
Lord are the same thing in this passage,
are they not? I believe so. Okay. So,
the law of Moses and the law of the Lord
are not two distinct laws. They're the
same law here. They're quotations from
the Torah given by God given through
Moses.
Okay. Ezra chapter 7. The book of
Ezra chapter 7.
um verse 11
uh in fact verse 10 if we can just start
with uh verse 10 of Ezra chapter 7
um we see the same thing there that uh
verse 10 for Ezra had devoted himself to
the study and observance of the law of
the Lord right to its teachings and
decrees um now if we keep
flowing. Um, we find there as well that
Azra is also a scribe not just in the
law of the Lord, but I think if we just
scroll down a bit there,
um, he's also called a teacher of the
law. He's also called a teacher of the
uh, the law of the God of heaven. And
he's also referred to as a scribe in the
law of Moses. And I know it's it it's
it's there in in Ezra
7. There again, you have the law of the
God of heaven. And he's also referred to
in Ezra 7 as a scribe in the law of
Moses. And it's in chapter 7 and verse
six. Yeah, verse six. If we can go back
to verse
six. So there it is, verse six. So just
as we saw there, as we saw in in Ezra,
thank you for that. Ezra came up from
Babylon. He was a teacher and wellversed
in the law of Moses, which the law lord,
the God of Israel given. So again, you
see here the uh the connection again,
Jose, that Ezra could be called a scribe
in the law of the Lord and the law of
Moses. And those two words, would you
agree law of the Lord, law of Moses are
being used synonymously and
interchangeably here? Sure. Okay. Very
good. So, let me ask you this question
then. Um, what are the two great
commandments in the law?
Two great commandments. Jesus, yeah.
Love the Lord your God with all your
heart, soul, and mind. Love your
neighbor as yourself. Okay. So, did he
say that upon these two commandments
hangs all the law and the prophets? did.
Okay. Where does the command to love the
Lord with all our heart, mind, and soul,
where does that appear?
Uh, what is it?
Yeah,
the So, you're right. Deuteronomy 6, uh,
4, 5, 6, and following, right? So,
you're to love the Lord your God with
all your heart, mind, and soul. Uh, is
that part of the ten commandments? Is
that one of the inscriptions, one of the
commands in the ten commandments? Well,
Jesus did. That was one of the
inscriptions. What Jesus said was on
this hang all the law and the prophets.
And so it is the foundation of it. Love
your whole heart mind. Very clear in the
ten commandments. I'm not going to take
other gods before. I'm not going to
commit. I Yeah, I get that Jose. I get
that. But but there is no greater
commandment than this one. He said, "And
the second is like unto it." And what is
the second of the great commandments of
God? The second one. Labor as yourself.
And where is that then? On the book of
Leviticus, but I'm not going to be able
to tell you the chapter. Chapter 19.
Well, you showed us Ezra, so I'll return
the favor. Leviticus 19 verse 18. Is
Leviticus 19 uh verse 18 part of the Ten
Commandments?
No.
So the greatest commandments in God's
law according to Jesus are the
commandments of love to love the Lord
our God with all our heart and the
second one is to love our neighbor. But
your argument that the ten commandments
were inside the ark of the covenant
shows that there's a distinction. And
yet Jesus is quoting from the books of
Moses, the
Torah. And he's quoting from those
books, from Deuteronomy 6 and Leviticus
19, to affirm that the greatest
commandments of God's law are not the
10, but rather the two great
commandments of God's law are the basis,
or if you will, the hooks upon which the
ten commandments rest. Would you agree
with that assessment?
Yes, I would. What I would say to that
is um again when we're talking about uh
the rest of the law outside of the ten
commandments, I would sit there and say
they have application. They're teaching
tools. They are shadows. They point to
things that we need to read and study
and pay attention to. That's why the
book of Hebrews is filled with
explanation on how that works. And so
the fact that Jesus would say on this
hang the law and the prophets to love
God with all your heart, soul, and mind,
love your neighbor as yourself. You see
that principle smack in the ten
commandments? Because of course, of
course, but you would agree that the
those commandments there are no greater
commandments than those two. Would you
agree with Jesus on that? Commandments.
Yes. And so they are greater than the
10. No, I I I wouldn't see that as
greater. I would see that as
complimentary again it's complimentary
but there are no greater commandments
than these two commandments right but
remember what the context of the
question master good teacher what is the
greatest of the commandments you know
that this was an argument that took
place between some of the rabbis they
had arguments about this when debating
the Torah and the law and what was
important and obvious Jesus gives the
explanation and sums it up citing his
own law. I don't have a problem with
that to explain what is at the
foundation of it all. So here's the
thing. I believe I I believe we are
living in the spirit and not simply of
the letter of the law. So love is the
spirit of the law. But living in the
spirit of the law doesn't cancel out the
letter of the law. It not all of a
sudden because the Bible says I
shouldn't hate because that's murder
does it automatically mean well now I
can actually physically murder. No.
Yeah. We're not saying that. We're not.
I'm simply making the claim that those
two great commandments are the greatest
and there's no greater commandment than
these. That's the words of the Lord
Jesus. It is. But again under the
context that he says on this hang the
law and the prophets we got to let all
his words speak. Of course. Of course.
Speak. Of course. So um outside of the
ten commandments are there any moral
laws uh moral aspects moral commandments
um outside of the ten commandments in
God's law? So in the rest of God's law,
there are further explanation and ex and
what we could say
expansions of what is found in the ten
commandments. And so obviously the the
laws about well if you killed someone on
accident versus if you did it on purpose
or if you bore false uh witness, right?
and versus
uh you know and and what would happen
and so ultimately yeah I mean um when
when when you're homosexuality if a man
lies with a man as he does with a woman
they shall surely be put to death that's
not in the ten commandments but that is
a moral law that God gave in Leviticus
18:22 and Leviticus 2013 it is but I
would argue it falls under the law you
shall not fornicate or commit adultery
it. But adultery, adultery by definition
is infidelity to a spouse, with another
person, another woman, another man. So
that's not technically homosexuality.
Yes. But you and I, you both know and
and many scholars have seen that the and
and including Jewish rabbis as well that
that law of adultery is pointing to any
kind of infidelity outside of the opaces
of a marriage between a man and a woman.
So that God would later on make it clear
and expand that by giving laws that a
man should not lie with a man as with a
woman. Makes total sense because he is
expanding on the fact that the only
person I should be lying with is my
wife. Of course. Of course. So we're not
arguing that. I'm simply arguing that
there are certain sexual deviant
behaviors like beastiality and
homosexuality that are not in the ten
commandments. Adultery is pretty pretty
specific in terms of definition. The
other word that we can talk about is
porna, the word where we get uh sexual
immorality from which covers everything
you're talking about. But let me let's
come back to Colossians 2:16. So in
Colossians 2:16 when Paul says that let
no one judge you concerning a festival,
a new moon or a Sabbath. These are all a
shadow of that which is to come which is
Christ. Um, would you agree that the
Sabbath in is included there with the
new moon celebrations and with the
annual feast and that they are all
pointing to Christ? You know, a body
casts a shadow, right? When you're out
in the sun, your body casts a shadow.
Well, Christ is the body and the law,
the Torah, the the Sabbath, the the the
new moons, the feasts, they're all
pointing to him.
So would you agree that the the Sabbath
mentioned in Colossians 2:16 is the
weekly Sabbath?
Yeah. So let me pause and say this for
those you know since you mentioned 7th
day Adventism right are very much
scholars in this area there there are
some uh differing views on this
interpretation. So yes, historically
some scholars have looked at this as
ceremonially and they have shown this
through the tripart uh aspect of new
moons uh festivals sabbaths. Um but I
would agree with uh another set of
scholars that hold to the concept that
yes this is a reference to the weekly
Sabbath but not in the context of simple
Sabbath keeping of no rest and ceasing
from your labor. I think if you spend
the time exeding this grammar a little
bit more, I think we'll find that the
concept of food and drink become the
actual emphasis here of this very shadow
because that same concept of food and
drink shows up again in Hebrews 10 when
we're talking about sacrifices, food and
drinks. And I think it's very clear when
you're looking at the Sabbath, the
Sabbath, feast days, and new moons. Yes,
they had certain ritual elements that
were involved in the uh parts of the law
that were not in the Ten Commandments
that he's basically saying, listen,
these are not things that you have to be
participating anymore in when you're
keeping the Sabbath. And I would say one
last thing to this um and then let you
continue. I think it also needs to be
understood that the context Colossians 2
begins with being not cheated through
philosophy and empty deceit. The
traditions of men, the the the ten
commandments is not a man-made
tradition. And when you come down to the
philosophies, it mentions it again later
on post uh verse 17. these concepts of
principles of the world. Verse 20, the
ten commandments are not principles of
the world. And so while this one and you
wrote in an article one time, this hapox
legon, this one place that you see the
Sabbath mentioned, we need to be a
little careful before we all of a sudden
take that one random statement that
mention the only time Paul does that and
go, you see, you don't have to keep the
fourth commandment when context and
grammar seems to argue differently with
that. So if we go up a bit, maybe Miles
if you can bring it up uh to verse 14.
Um because because you you were
mentioning uh verse 14. Yes. Um look at
verse uh 12. Um so what you have here in
Colasse is clearly a Jew a Judaizing
group. Um which has some Gnostic
elements to it. There's no doubt about
that. I mean he talks about circumcision
which is a Jewish practice. There's no
doubt about that. That's a Jewish
practice. Now if you go on um 13, when
you were dead in your sins and in the
uncircumcision of your flesh, God made
you alive with Christ, he forgave us all
our sins, having cancelled the charge of
our legal indebtness which stood against
us and condemned us and he has taken it
away, nailing it to the cross. Now he
nailed something to the cross. He
cancelled the charge of our legal
indebtness. Having disarmed the powers
and authorities, he made a public
spectacle of them trying triumphing over
them by the cross. And then that's when
he goes into verse 16. Therefore, and
why we must always ask why is the word
therefore? Why is it therefore? It's
therefore because of this. Don't let
anyone judge you by what you eat or
drink. Mosaic uh prescriptions. Don't
eat this. You can only eat that. um uh
don't let them judge you about a
religious festival, a new moon
celebration or Sabbath day. So clearly,
Jose, following Paul's logic here, that
that which the the the lawful
commandments that were against us
because we were debtors to the law,
Christ took that upon himself. He kept
the law perfectly on our behalf and he
canceled the debt. He nailed it to his
cross. And because of that, we're not to
let anyone judge us about the Sabbath,
new moons, annual festivals, and and so
if you argue, Jose, that the Sabbath
here, Yes. and thank you. You're the
first Adventist I ever met who's
actually finally admitted that the word
there means the Sabbath day Sabbath.
But yeah,
yeah, only Advent as their theologian.
So here's the thing with as we study 7th
day Adventists have always been open to
the fact that we got to study and grow
and that's why sometimes you're going to
see articles out there where you'll see
one theologian say this and another
theologian say that as we're wrestling
with certain passages because we believe
that is part of ex Jesus. Now, very
respectfully, let me just say that I do
believe this concept that you're coming
at is poor ex Jesus of this passage. I
mean that very respectfully as you might
say of me and I understand that. But
what I would say is when you're looking
at this festivals, new moons, Sabbaths,
food, and drink, Paul, who was an expert
in the law, he knew the Tanakh. He knew
the Torah, the Neim, the Keptim, he knew
it very well. He cites it all the time.
And so when he's citing these things,
it's interesting that throughout
uh the Old
Testament, you can find this tripartade
mix where it's talking about new moons,
feeding one minute foods and drinks and
all these aspects that are involved in
them. And every time they are referring
to the
ritual aspects involved with the
celebration of these days. I would also
then mention I agree with you that 14
and 15 is dealing with the cancelling of
debt. Praise God that Jesus died for the
condemnation that is on me from the law.
I mean that's reality. I mean, that's
one of the reasons I can't just do away
with the Ten Commandments like that. And
I'll tell you why. Because Jesus died on
the cross because of that condemnation
that rests on humanity for breaking that
law. And
time go ahead.
All right, gentlemen. Again, another
great lively exchange. We will now
transition into the final period of the
cross exam. Jose, your second 20-minut
period will begin when you begin
speaking, sir.
All
right. Well, Doc, I'm going to tell you,
you have uh given me my first engagement
in a public debate. Well, I'm glad I
have I have studied uh debate for a very
long time. And by the way, one of your
good friends, it's one of my favorite
apologists, Dr. James White. Love that
guy. Yes. Um, I don't agree with
everything, but I love a lot of the
things that he uh does really, really
well. Um, and so I appreciate that. So,
thank you for for this moment. Um, all
right. So, I want to pick up a little
bit where we left off last time. Um, we
were talking what is written in stone,
right? The Ten Commandments. Do you see
no distinction with the fact that not
only are they written in stone, but
they're written in the finger of
God? And we know that Jesus is Yahweh.
He is the I am. He is the creator.
That's why they wanted to stone him. So
it ultimately means that the ten
commandments, he did not leave them to
Moses to write. You know this. He
literally with his own
finger wrote them with stone. Jesus
himself pre-incarnate Jesus and handed
it to Moses to place within the ark
which was covered by the mercy seat
which you and I agree is a picture of
Jesus. Our propitiation, our mercy seat
very much so. Our atonement. So my
question to you is why do you think that
God
Jesus wrote with his own finger the ten
commandments and then left the rest of
the laws for Moses to write down as
such? Do you not see a distinction
there? Well, there's obviously a
distinction in that one was written with
stone, but those commandments are also
repeated in the book next to the the the
ark of the covenant. And just because
they're written in stone doesn't I mean,
if you want to know the conceptual
reason for that is that the tablets of
the law were a witness to them. They
were they were a witness to them. And
that's why one of the reasons why the
tabernacle was called the tent of
witness and so because it contained the
tablets of the law and the ark of the
covenant. And so the stones would
represent the witness of God against
them. Just like later on Joshua of
course would set up the stone at
Sheckchum as a testimony against the
Israelites. I'm not comparing that with
with God's writing of the of the
Decalogue. But at the end of the day, I
don't see that they're altogether
different because all scripture is God
breathed and it is it is profitable for
teaching and rebuke. So there isn't this
idea that well the ten commandments are
greater uh than the other commandments
of god. They are given by the same God.
And even though he utilized his finger
to to to write the the 10 words the
devarim on on stone doesn't take away
from the fact that his his written word
written by prophets and by Moses and so
forth. They are of equal value. And
that's one of the things that solos
scripura maintains is that all of
scripture without
discrimination is equally and
authoritatively authoritatively the word
of God. Amen. So I don't look at to to
me the the the New Testament law is not
the ten commandments. The new testament
law is the law of Christ. And the law of
Christ is the law of love. And the law
of love maintains that if we love God
with all our heart, mind, and soul, and
love our neighbor as oursel, then we
have fulfilled all the law. That's what
Paul says. Love fulfills the law. Agree
that Christ wrote the commandments with
his own law. Sure. Absolutely. No doubt
about I believe it. Yes. Well, I find
interesting that you make the statement
that, well, I don't believe that one is
greater than the
other. You just made a similar argument.
Moses Moses broke those. Okay. Moses
broke those. You're break you're
breaking up with Sorry, you're breaking
up. I didn't catch what you said there.
Sorry. I know. That's the the beauty
this mix, right? We talk over each other
when it's online like that. Let let me
let me explain what I mean by that. All
right. when we were talking about the
Abrahamic covenant and the uh sadetic
covenant and so on and so forth and you
said well one is greater and one
supersedes and I said yes but I'm
looking at that being complimentary for
its purpose and it continues as things
are revealed well you didn't accept that
argument but now when I'm asking you
about the law written with Christ's
finger compared to everything else. You
go, "Well, I don't really think one is
greater than the other. They're
complimentary." Uh, what are we doing
here? Yeah. Yeah. Let me explain.
Because the ten commandments is part of
the to is part of the law. It's the same
law. It's not separate from the law of
Moses. The law is a unit. And the law,
while it has ceremonial, moral, and and
civil aspects to it, it is still the
law. and and therefore it's not, oh, I'm
keeping only 10. Well, there's other
another 603 commandments that God gave
as well in addition to those. That law
has come to an end in Christ. We are now
under a new law because the Old
Testament law, under the Old Testament
law, Jesus Christ cannot be your savior
or your mediator. Because if the Mosaic
law was still enforced, Jesus Christ
could not be a priest. only a Levite
could become a priest. And so in order
for Christ to become a priest of the
order of Melzdc, as Hebrews says, the
law had to be changed. And in Hebrews 8,
you mentioned Hebrews 8, Jose, earlier.
Hebrews 8 says that he rendered the
first covenant
obsolete. And that's the same language
Paul uses in 2 Corinthians 3 where he
talks about the tablets of the law as a
ministry of death. And he says that that
glory is vanishing away and is being
rendered obsolete. It is being
abolished. And what replaces the stone
tablets is the spirit of God who writes
his law in our hearts. That's covenant.
So all that to
say, I don't obey the ten commandments
because Moses said it. I keep the
commandments that Christ has enunciated
in the new covenant. Jesus gave over 400
commandments in the New
Testament. And so the law that I'm under
is not the Old Testament law at Sinai. I
am under the law of Christ, the new
covenant law based on better promises.
I've entered into my rest in Christ. And
and I know the topic today is on the
Sabbath. You know, we can we could talk
about the first day and the significance
in early Christianity with the first day
and the resurrection, but my whole point
is to say that I'm no longer under that
law. I'm under the law of Christ. And
that is law of Christ does not repeat
the fourth commandment. So, so where I
feel where I see major contradiction
there is we go back
Christ was the one. Now again, we may
want to ignore that distinction, but
Christ is the one who wrote with his
finger those 10 dars, the 10 part of the
law. Yes. That part down with his own
finger. I strange that
Jesus would
die to then do away with his own law
that he wrote with his finger and then
say, "Oh, this is my law." Well, wait a
second. And and I'm going to give an
example and I want to ask you what think
about this. Sure. Um in uh let me see
here. Give me a second. In Deuteronomy
chapter 18, okay, stay with me there for
a moment. Uh and and allow me I'm going
to try to say make this very quickly.
Deuteronomy,
we see that Moses prophesied that a
prophet would come. Right. Right. 15
through uh 18 specifically. Right. And
we know prophet that was to come
foretold that would be like Moses. We
believe thatic prophecy. You agree? Yes.
Okay. It's a messianic prophecy. Now,
here's something interesting that I
find. Come to uh and we know Jesus is
way more than a prophet, but in this
context, it's a prophet that's coming.
Right. Right. Let's come to Deuteronomy
chapter 13. Deuteronomy chapter 13 1-5.
Deuteronomy 13. It's interesting in
1-5, Moses gives some rules about the
coming prophet. Yes. that was that any
and not not a coming prophet but any
prophet that would come uh to Israel.
Right. Right. Um uh so uh one of the
things that I would say to that is in
sorry something popped up here I think
from Streamyard. That's kind of why I'm
hesitating here. But Deuteronomy chapter
13:1-5 points out that um if a prophet
comes amongst you Mhm. and tells you,
hey, and and and and this is one of
God's laws, right? Um verses verse two,
let us go after other gods which you
have not known, and let us serve them.
What are you supposed to do with that
prophet?
Yeah. You're supposed to you're supposed
to reject that prophet and ultimately uh
that prophet is to be put to death.
Yeah. He needs to be killed. Right.
Right. So I find it interesting. So So
follow with me. Thank you for answering
that question. Isaiah chapter 8.
Similarly, Isaiah chapter 8, this is
years later of course. Mhm. But in
Isaiah chapter 8, we find Isaiah verse
uh 20 in the context of who are you
supposed to be listening to, right? Um
make a statement. And in that statement
verse 20 he says to the law and to the
testimony if they do not speak according
to this word it is because there is no
light in them. Yeah.
So Jesus is the coming prophet. False
prophets one of the ways of identifying
them is all the people to turn away from
God's law. And Isaiah
mentions that those who come must speak
according to the law and according to
the testimony. Right? So knowing all of
that, would you still say that Jesus's
mission ushered in something that would
contradict the law he previously himself
gave? Okay, we need to we need to be
careful because uh there's there's a
context there and and the word law can
also refer to that which has been
revealed not only through Moses but the
word law could also refer to the whole
testament right in John 10 for example
John chapter 10 uh verse uh 34 is it not
written in your law I have said you are
gods quoting Psalm 826 and he calls it
the law the Nomos in Greek. Um Paul
refers to uh the women being solded in
the churches and then he quotes from
Genesis. Um and he and of course he
calls that the law as well. And then he
quotes from uh Isaiah 28 about speaking
in foreign tongues and he calls that the
law. And so when the Bible speaks of the
law and the prophets, it's it's an idiom
for what God has revealed his
revelation. So Isaiah 7:20 clearly is
saying to the law and if you looked at
the the version the version that um that
Miles had up there it says God's
instruction which is what the word Torah
also means. It means instruction verse
20 there God's instruction which also
means Torah. So the law of course is the
standard by which God uh that by which
God um has revealed himself. But that
law, the Christian is not an
antonyomian. We hold to the law of
Christ. And the law of Christ contains
all of the commandments that Jesus and
the apostles gave us. And part of those
commandments in the new covenant is
beware of false prophets, prove all
things, test all things, hold to that
which is good. How do you know if a
spirit is from God or from or from or
from Antichrist? So, so all I'm saying
there is that through God's redemptive
history, God's revelations have always
been the norm to judge what is right and
what is wrong. But that also includes
the law of Christ. And so, how do I know
someone's a false prophet in the New
Testament? If anyone says that Jesus
Christ did not come in the flesh, he is
Antichrist. It's 1 John 4. Uh, and so
we're not saying, "Oh, let's just get
rid of the law." What we're saying is in
the new covenant, the law of Christ is
not the law of Moses that has been
revealed at Sinai. And that's where I
think talking past each other. And I
guess it's just my mind going, you're
making now this distinction between
Christ's law and the law of Moses when
you agreed earlier that it's Christ
himself.
Yes. who wrote the Ten Commandments on
those tablets of stone, not Moses. Now,
he verbally inspired Moses to write
everything else down, but not the Ten
Commandments. So when you keep doing
this Christ law versus this law, if
you're doing your systematic theology
and Jesus is the I
am, then it's like saying Jesus came,
okay, way with his own law. Okay, let me
put it this way. Hold on. Let me put it
this way. Did Jesus tell Moses to uh
offer up sacrifices um to offer up um
the day of atonement sacrifice? Did
Jesus command Moses to do that?
You are asking me a question technically
that that that Okay, I'm sorry. I'm
sorry. You're asking the question. Okay,
let me put it this way. Let me put it
this way. to to say that Jesus says
something in the New Testament that
contravenes what he says in the Old
Testament. You accept that on the basis
of the fact that Christ has sacrificed
has set aside and put away all the all
the animal sacrifices of the Old
Testament which he commanded himself.
And so I don't see what the difference
is
between we have set aside that which
Christ has commanded and yet superseded
with his new covenant. I don't see what
the difference is between the ten
commandments and Christ's law in the new
covenant which is the law of love which
fulfills all of it. Right? I agree.
Christ gave all of it. The Tanakh is
ultimately all from him. Totally agree.
But when who gave the law Jesus the
lawgiver, he distinctly wrote part of
that law himself. He didn't leave it to
man. Think about this. You mentioned
Moses breaking the law even after he
broke the ten commandments re he had to
carve out the new stones, right? But who
wrote them down the second time? Yeah,
of course there's no debate there. But
that's totally different than what he
did with the rest of those laws which
yet which is why I'm saying you do you
not see the distinction that the rest of
those laws like in the book of Hebrews
which does not mention the Sabbath does
not mention the ten commandments does
not mention that which was written with
Christ's finger it mentions those things
related to food drink sacrifices priests
those laws and it's not tell that those
laws are irrelevant. It's telling you
that those laws pointed to the one who
is relevant. Do you not see that? No.
Because they're given by the same God.
They are equal to each other. I I
there's nothing in scripture. In fact, 2
Corinthians 3 points out that the
writing of the spirit on the heart, the
tablets of men's hearts in is greater
than the ten commandments written on
stone. Because Paul calls the ten
commandments written on stone. He calls
that a ministry or administration of
death. And he calls the writing in the
hearts of God's people by the Holy
Spirit. He calls that he says that is
glorious. That is not only glorious, but
we are being changed into the glory of
the Lord. And so in 2 Corinthians 3,
Paul tells us that the law of Christ,
which is the law of the spirit, who
inscribes that law in our hearts
according to Jeremiah 31:31 and
following, that law is greater than the
law written on stone, which Paul says
brought death to us. Those tablets,
Jose, will bring death to you because
you cannot keep them. Every time you
violate those tablets, you become a
debtor to the law. You become a lawb
breakaker. And the only one who could
perfectly keep those tablets and all the
laws. Not just that, he kept all of them
from A to Z. Christ observed all of
them. In other words, the reason why
Paul called the tablets on stone, the
writing on stone, a ministry of death,
is because they will destroy you. They
will. That's why Paul says, "The law
killed me." And so what we need to be
reminded of is we need the law of the
spirit which supersedes the law of the
tablets. Yes. So you said Paul, ministry
of death, right? One minute left. I
recognize that Romans 7 makes it clear,
does it not? That the reason the law is
a ministry of death is because the sin
that lives in me. Is that not correct?
Correct. And you just good. Yeah. And
you cannot keep that law perfectly. We
we we can try, but we're law breakers.
Yeah. Let me ask you this, though. The
new covenant says he's going to write
that law in my hearts and minds. Is that
him giving you the ability to do that
which you cannot
excellent point Jose the new covenant
law we he says I will cause them to walk
in my ways because he's giving us the
holy spirit I will put my spirit in them
in the old covenant they didn't have
that they didn't have the promise of the
holy spirit but in the new covenant he
places his holy spirit in us and he
makes us to walk in his ways time.
The new covenant is greater than the
tablets of the law and the new and the
old covenant.
Gentlemen, that was a very great and
lively back and forth. Great
cross-examination. Thank you both for
the lively back and forth. We're going
to transition now to our closing
statements before we get into a long
list of audience Q&A. The closing
statements will begin with Tony giving
Jose the final word since Tony had the
final word in the openings. Tony, your
five minute closing statement will begin
sir when or your time will begin when
you begin speaking.
Okay. So if you remember uh in my
opening statement I talked about uh the
fact that uh there's no debate in my
mind about which day the Sabbath day
was. The Sabbath day um is designated in
the Old Testament as the seventh day.
And that Sabbath was given by God to
Israel. And the silence of the book of
Genesis on Abraham observing it, Isaac
observing it, Jacob observing it, Enoch.
Enoch um walked with God. He didn't
observe Sabbath and yet he was taken by
God. Um none of them kept the Sabbath.
Uh some of the Jews were so
uncomfortable about this idea that in
the book of Jubilees, which is a book
that is part of the pseudapigrapha, they
have Abraham and Isaac and Jacob keeping
tabernacles, Pentecost, Passover. uh
they're keeping um all the feasts
mentioned in Leviticus 23 because they
were uncomfortable with the fact that
Genesis was silent about them keeping
those laws and they based it on Genesis
25:6 just like Jose based his argument
on that to argue that the Sabbath may
have been observed by the patriarchs. So
the the deafening silence uh speaks
volumes there. The the first appearance
is in in Exodus 16 where God reveals his
Sabbath to Israel. He tells them
specifically that this is a seal between
you and I, that I am the Lord who
sanctifies you. The death penalty, if
you worked on the Sabbath, it would
result in death uh on the spot. Um, and
then we find throughout the Old
Testament that the failure of Israel to
observe the Sabbath is what led to their
captivity in Babylon for 70 years
because they did not give the land its
Sabbath rest. Every seven years they
were cast into Babylon for 70 years so
that the land might rest. And so you
will notice that throughout the Old
Testament, the Sabbath is part of the
law. The law is a unit. uh the idea that
the law is broken into ceremonial and
moral and and civil. The the first
theologians to talk about this, this
begins with Thomas Aquinas in the 13th
century and then of course John Calvin
picks that up in the 16th century and
John Kelvin uh of course makes that um a
feature of of many Protestant uh
churches today. But if we look
consistently at the Bible, the Sabbath
was part of the sign covenant that God
gave to Israel. And with the prophecies
of the coming Messiah, we find that the
Israelites broke that law, that law, not
laws, that law, that unit. And God
promised that he would make a new
covenant with the the people of Israel
because it was to them that the Messiah
would come first. Jesus came first for
Israel and then by extension to the
Gentiles. Now with the coming of Jesus,
Jesus lived under the law. He kept the
Sabbath. He kept the feast days. He kept
circumcision. He kept kosher. He kept
all the laws that were uh written down
in the Torah. But what we find is that
with the coming of Jesus, the prophets
told us that not only would he bring a
new covenant, but that covenant would be
different from the Mosaic covenant. And
so with the death of Jesus, he brings
the law to an end. Romans 10:4, Christ
is the end of the law to all who
believe. And so that word telos could
mean not just the end, but he is the
goal. The goal of the law and the end.
And so with the death of Christ, Hebrews
tells us he inaugurates a new testament,
a new will. When does a will take
effect? When somebody dies. So Christ
dies, he inaugurates a new covenant,
better promises, better priesthood. The
law of Moses had to stop because it
would have prevented Christ from being a
priest. No priest could enter that
office unless he was a Levite. Christ
was not a Levite. He was from the tribe
of Judah. And so what we find is one
minute remaining. He inaugurates a new
covenant. The Sabbath has come to an end
as it was the sign of the Mosaic
covenant. The Mosaic covenant ends.
Thereby the sign ends with it. Christ
brings about a new covenant. Under the
new covenant, believers are free to
worship God any day of the week. The
church from its earliest beginnings did
regard the first day with significance
because of the resurrection of Christ. I
didn't go into that area today because
that is not the title of our debate, but
it's very clear that the New Testament
community saw themselves as a new people
under the law of Christ, which is the
law of love. And when we love Christ,
when we love God, when we love our
neighbor, we fulfill all law. And so we
are not under the Mosaic law. Therefore,
Christians are not obligated to keep the
seventh day Sabbath that was given to
Israel and not to the Gentiles. Thank
you for your attention and God bless.
Perfect timing, right at the five minute
mark. Thank you for that closing
statement, Tony.
We will now hop over to Jose and you
will have your five minute closing, sir.
Your time will begin when you begin
speaking.
All right. Again, this has been uh an
awesome experience. I've enjoyed it. Um
I appreciate it. Again, I would simply
just say that uh I struggle still to
understand as I've made clear and we
spent a lot of time in cross-examination
on this that if Christ is the lawgiver
and I I don't have the disagreement that
the law is one uh element but it has
different applications and it has
different purposes. One, I believe that
when you're looking at what was written
with Christ's own finger, as I said in
my opening statement, defines
sin. That's why you find the Sabbath in
the Ten Commandments. But as I said in
my opening statement, you do not find
Passover, atonement, uh any of these
other aspects. You don't find them in
the finger of Christ written on that
stone of tablets. You don't see that
there. But yet what you do find in the
book of Hebrews and I would even argue
Colossians 2 that the part of the law
that dealt with ritual sacrifices and
dealt with um uh drinks and beverages
and all those things. Those laws that
pointed to the mission of the Messiah,
the mission of Jesus, what he would do
on our behalf. I believe those laws were
relevant, had a purpose. They're still
important, but they're important as we
recognize what Jesus has fulfilled. That
is
type meeting anti-ype. That's the whole
point of the book of Hebrews. Symbolism
meeting its reality. And so when I'm
looking at this aspect of God's law that
defines sin, I would not know sin unless
I knew that the law said, "Thou shalt
not covet." So when I hear things like
law of death and all these things, yes,
of course, outside of
Jesus, the only thing the law does, as I
said in my opening statement, is point
out my sin, points out my rebellion,
points out that I deserve to be under
the wrath of God and under condemnation.
But as I've also stated, because of
Jesus, I am justified by grace through
faith in him. And now that I am that
that I am, what does Hebrews 8 says? Now
Jesus who with his finger wrote down his
law on tablets of stone now takes that
same we could say finger
illustratively and writes that law in my
heart and in my mind so that now I no
longer want to live in rebellion to God.
The old covenant and the new covenant
difference. What messed up that covenant
was not God. It was the people of God.
The ones that did not
keep their end of the covenant. But God
always keeps his covenant. He always
keeps his promises. And thus his law is
still of importance to us today. I think
it gets difficult when we start playing
the game of the law of Christ
versus the law of Moses when that law
written with his finger is of Christ.
I'm going to keep making that emphasis
because that is super super important to
me in this discussion. One minute
remaining. And so I want to encourage
you to keep studying this. I want to
encourage you to stay challenged in
this. Uh as I've said, this is my first
time uh entering and engaging in a
debate of this matter. My ultimate
desire is that we would all learn to
live glorifying God, live in harmony
with who he is, and allow him to
transform our hearts and our minds and
to help us live in harmony with his
precepts which he has uh given to us.
And so I hope we continue learning and I
hope we continue growing. God bless you
all.
All right. Thank you,
Jose. Thank you both so much for being
here. This was a great, great, great
back and forth. We're going to
transition now into our list of
questions. I hope you guys are prepped
for that. Just to remind everybody, each
debater will have one minute to respond
to each question. just to make sure if
we have questions p primarily coming in
for one of them at least both of them
will get to engage. So we are going to
go down the list now starting with the
first ones that were sent in. This one
is to
both. This person asks if we are under
the new
covenant. Why are you both still trying
to teach your neighbor the law if the
law is written on your heart? Sounds
like a question pertaining to Jeremiah
31. Tony, we will begin with you. You
have one minute to answer, sir. Okay.
The first thing I would say is I don't
teach law first and foremost. I teach
them grace and then I bring in the law
to show them their sin and their need
for Christ. And so the law was given
that sin might be revealed. and the law
was given um so that we would be as
Charles Spurgeon said that we would be
uh forced to the foot of the cross to
put our trust in Christ. So the way I
put it is this way. The law shows me
that I'm a sinner. And so when I look in
the mirror, so you know when we guys
look in the mirror and we have some
stubble on our face, well, we don't take
the mirror off the wall and start
shaving with it because that's not the
function of the mirror to shave you.
you're shaved by grace. And so the razor
of God's grace will shave you. But it's
not the mirror that can shave you. It
shows you you need a shave. And so the
reason why uh we appeal to the law of
Christ in New Testament, which is also
the law of God, um we do that as Martin
Luther, the great reformer, taught law
and gospel because we show them their
need for Christ.
Time. Thank you, Tony. All right, Jose,
you have one minute to respond as well.
Great question. I would simply say that
it doesn't say that we will not teach
each other what God's law is. Says we're
not going to say know the Lord. All
right? And so as people come to accept
Jesus as their savior and lord, he
instructs them his grace. I agree with
Dr. Costa will instruct. That's what
Titus chapter 2 talks about. And it also
talks about it will instruct us not to
live lawlessly. And again, obviously our
difference there is going to be what are
we talking about when we say living
lawlessly? Um, but I do believe that
we're taught by Jesus in Matthew 28,
teaching men to observe whatsoever
things I have taught you. All right? And
so there's an aspect of the new covenant
that involves teaching so that we do
come to that point where we know God.
Perfect. Exactly one minute. All right.
The next
question, this person didn't actually
have a question. They just had a
comment, but we're going to bring it out
for them. They said, "Adventist
arguments are always the same. Very
predictable." All right. Thank you for
sharing that.
Mike Coburn has a question for Jose. He
says, "How does an Adventist determine
what constitutes true Sabbathkeeping
today in a way that doesn't violate the
law?" Jose, we will begin with you and
your time will begin when you begin
talking.
All right. We got to let the Bible speak
for itself. I mean, the Bible makes it
clear that that it is no working or it
is not letting people work for you
unnecessary labor.
The Bible lays out with the aspects of
not performing business in the book of
Nehemiah. Nehemiah teaches the people
the Sabbath is not a day for uh business
and labor uh of of that nature when you
don't have to be doing that. Isaiah 58
also points out that the Sabbath was
meant to be a day where you put aside
your own things, your own conversations,
your own ways of thinking and acting,
and you dedicate that time to your
growth and to uh getting to know the
Lord uh even better. And so we would let
the Bible only speak for itself.
All right, Tony, you have one minute to
answer the question as well.
Um, well, I mean, it depends on on which
uh which Adventist you asked. Um, so
it's it's I' I've heard Adventists
answer that question in different ways.
Um, most of the time it has to do with
worship. Um, if you look at the original
giving of the Sabbath in in Exodus 16,
nothing is said about worship. All it
says is stay in your homes and rest.
There's nothing set said about going to
the tabernacle or or engaging in
worship. That begins to develop in in in
Old Testament history. Uh definitely by
the time you get to Jesus, Luke 4:16, uh
he goes to the synagogue on the Sabbath
day. But even the observance of the
Sabbath evolved. It developed. So
originally when it was given by God,
they were just told to stay home and
rest. That's the command. Nothing is
said about worship. the priests were the
ones who were busy uh committing
sacrifices and so on, but the actual
aspect of corporate worship is something
that doesn't happen until much later.
And so there's an evolution there.
All
right, the next question individual
asks, "Will Jesus save those who reject
Sabbathkeeping and choose to worship God
on Sunday? Are their prayers not
accepted by Christ? Jose, we will begin
with you, sir.
All right, great question. Uh, I think
this all depends on whether this person
is doing it knowingly and rebelliously.
I mean, I would say that no real
Christian is going to live in rebellion
against God. Um, so if a Christian knows
to do good and knows what is right and
chooses not to do
it, I don't know. That creates a
problem. Um, as far as are our prayers
not accepted by Christ? I mean, I think
that if you're living in rebellion,
unrepentant sin of any sort,
uh, and you're seeking God to do things
for you outside of save you and change
you and work in your heart, I think, um,
we're using God as a genie rather than
as our creator and our king.
All right, Tony, one minute to you as
well.
Yeah. I think what what we tend to hear
often from our Adventist friends is that
we're saved by faith, faith alone, but
by the end of it is you're you're saved
by faith, but you're kept by law. And
that's a contradiction of Galatians
1:6-9. That that's the other gospel. And
so, because the Sabbath day has ended
with the passing of the law, that is the
Old Testament law, Christians are no
longer under the Sabbath. Paul could
say, "I'm no longer under the law. I'm
under grace." And so the law cannot
touch you because of the righteousness
of Christ. And so if you're a believer
in the Lord Jesus Christ and you worship
him on the first day of the week in in
commemoration of his resurrection and
his victory over death, um then of
course that's acceptable. That's what
Paul says in Romans 14:5-6. One man
esteems one day the same and everyone
else may esteem it holier than another.
One day holier than another. uh let
everyone be convinced but the one who
observes the day observes it to the
Lord. So if you observe Monday to the
Lord then it's to the Lord glorified and
the same applies to Sunday the Lord's
day.
All right. Same individual has another
question. Question to
Jose. Will Goliath the giant who was
killed by David be judged for not
keeping the Sabbath? Jose, you have one
minute.
I love this question. It's actually uh a
fun one. I I think Goliath is going to
not be saved for a lot other reasons uh
than just the Sabbath. I think we're
talking here about rebellion against God
and rebellion against his people. That's
why I said what I said before. Jesus
didn't die on the cross for me to stay
in a rebellious state. He died on the
cross so that I can walk in harmony with
him as I let Christ live in and through
me. So, is Goliath not making it because
of the Sabbath? I think he's not making
it for a lot of other
reasons. I think you're muted,
Miles. You're muted. You're muted. Tony,
anything you want to add to that? You
have one minute. Yeah. Well, of course,
he's going to be judged for his
paganism, worshiping other gods rather
than the one true God. Uh, which he's
guilty of because Paul says that
everyone has that that moral aspect in
in their conscience. Romans 1.
Therefore, they're without excuse.
That's Paul's whole argument. Um, but
but this raises an interesting question.
Uh, God did not condemn Babylon for
Sabbath breaking or Egypt uh or uh
Assyria or Fistia. Um God condemned them
for other things like immorality, sexual
immorality, murder uh and so on. But not
once, not once did God condemn the
gentile nations for Sabbath breaking. He
only condemned Israel. Why? Because it
was his sign with them. It was his
covenant sign with them. It was the
wedding band between him and Yahweh and
his bride, Israel. That was their
wedding band. And they violated that
wedding band, that wedding vow that they
made to Yahweh. So, of course, God would
not condemn the nations because he
number one, he's not married to them.
Number two, he holds them culpable
because there is image. But the Sabbath
was not given to the Gentile nations.
All right, the next question for Jose.
You mentioned you do not believe the
Sabbath is required to be kept for
salvation. However, Ellen White wrote
that it was. Who to believe? Your time
will begin when you begin, sir.
Well, obviously this is a question, not
exactly the premise of the debate. I
would simply say uh when I've read Ellen
White's statements about the Sabbath,
the principle is simple. If the ten
commandments still stand, all 10, the
Sabbath included, then the reality is
that breaking the Sabbath is as breaking
any of the other commandments. And so
that creates a problem because if I
choose rebelliously to break any of
God's laws, saying I'm just going to do
what I feel like doing because I want to
do it, then that's a problem. And now I
have a little bit of a difference with
my opponent on this uh kept by the law
business. No, I'm kept by grace, but
grace puts me in harmony with God's law.
All right.
Tony, anything you want to add to that?
You have one minute. Yeah. So, I I think
the important thing here is to recognize
the New Testament is the commentary on
the old. Uh we should never interpret
the New Testament in light of the old.
Um we should always interpret the old in
light of the new. And this is a maxim
that Jesus taught us and also that the
great fathers of the church like
Augustine taught us as well. Um but we
need to understand that the New
Testament has already responded to this
question. Uh Romans 14 again 5-6 Paul
says there's difference of opinion about
the observance of days. Paul did not
make that a central feature of the
Christian faith. He called it it's it's
called the diaphora disputable matters.
And one of them is that some people
regard every day alike or the same or
others regard one day holier than
another. But let everyone be convinced
in his own mind. And if you observe the
day, the day, not the Sabbath, not the
first day, not the second day, not if
you observe the day, it is unto the to
the Lord that you observe it. So
remember, uh, and Jose did not dispute
this, nine of the ten commandments are
repeated in the New Testament, a time
and to keep the Sabbath.
All
right, another question for Jose. The
electricity grid keeps hospitals, jails,
and SDA churches running. Are workers
there breaking the Sabbath? You have one
minute when you begin speaking, sir.
Well, the question is, is workers
referring to electricity or is workers
referring to uh I'm assuming it's the
electrical grid. And so, I would say
just one clarification. I think he's
saying that the the workers there are
utilizing things like electricity and
then the electric the electrical grid is
causing people to have to work to
maintain such a thing. Okay. Um if if
that's if that's what we're saying then
I would simply say that look what is
necessary is necessary. That's the
Sabbath is not dealing with oh lawful to
do good on the Sabbath. Don't forget
that Jesus's debate with the rabbis was
over their extra stuff. This stuff about
you can't turn on a light because you're
starting a fire on the Sabbath or you
got to take a light bulb out of your
fridge or you're breaking the law.
That's tradition. That's not God's law.
But helping someone because the
electrical grid went down and they got
to make sure it stays and get it back up
again so hospitals can keep moving. That
is lawful to do good. But we're talking
about unnecessary labor. Working at a
restaurant, generally speaking, is
unnecessary. That's not work that should
be happening on the Sabbath day.
Something like that. Perfect time once
again. All right, Tony, your turn. I I
would just say that there is some
inconsistency with our Adventist friends
because it does say that they're not to
kindle a fire on the Sabbath day. Um,
you know, do you do you start a a fire
in the fireplace on the Sabbath day? Uh,
we're forbidden uh to to light a fire.
Um, you're also forbidden uh you're
commanded actually to kill anyone who
breaks the Sabbath. And so under the
Mosaic law, we read in the book of
Numbers that someone actually profane
the Sabbath by doing something like
picking up sticks. That's all they were
doing. Maybe they were picking up sticks
to kindle a fire. And what did the Lord
say? Put him to death for breaking my
Sabbath. And so this goes back to the
question of how you observe the Sabbath.
I mean, of course, the rabbis have
extrapolated what does that mean? Don't
light a fire. Well, that means in in
modern terminology, don't turn on a
light bulb. Don't don't don't use
electricity because that would be akin
to the lighting of a fire. That but I'm
not I'm not advocating for that for the
rabbitic interpretation. All I'm saying
is there's many injunctions on the
Sabbath that adventist and one of them
is you're not to kindle a fire on the
Sabbath day.
All
right, next one. Here's just a comment,
but we still want to bring it out for
the super chat. The Sabatis Moss Hebrews
4 is a perpetual rest like God rested
perpetually after his creative work.
That's a gospel truth. Thank you for
that, Rick's Bible
study. Jonathan has a question. He asks,
"Is keeping the Saturday Sabbath a
salvational issue?" kind of the same as
what was asked before, but we'll still
give you the time for uh one minute,
Jose. All
right. Salvation no more than any of the
other ten commandments. So, the
consistency is there are ten
commandments. This is the consistency if
we're going to agree to that. I mean, my
opponent and I don't agree with that.
But if we're going to agree that there
are ten commandments, all right, should
we continue in sin, which is lawb
breakaking, that grace may abound?
Certainly not. So, it becomes the
salvation issue if I believe that Jesus
died to keep me in sin. Uh, he didn't
die to keep me in sin. He died to take
me out of sin. And so, you know, I have
a couple more seconds. So, let me just
say this. I would say that therefore we
just need to be paying attention to
whether or not the Ten Commandments is
important for the Christian or not, for
the saved person or not. But we're not
saved by the law, and we're not kept by
it either.
All right, Tony, you have one minute as
well, sir. Yeah. The same apostle that
said that you know should we live in sin
that grace may abound certainly not is
the same apostle who said whoever
observes the day observes to the Lord
let no one pass judgment on you
Colossians 2:16 he's the same apostle
who said therefore let no one judge you
about a festival a new moon or a Sabbath
day all of these were a shadow of that
which was to come the shadow of the
reality which is Christ and in Hebrews 8
we're told that the law the first
covenant was rendered
obsolete. Well, if it's obsolete, then
there's a need for a new covenant. And
that's what Hebrews says. If the first
one wasn't was did not lack anything,
there'd be no need for a new one. And
so, the Apostle Paul has already
answered this question. That's why
there's no direct commandment by the
Apostle Paul in his letters or any of
the apostles about keeping the Sabbath
day or the fourth day of the uh excuse
me, the fourth commandment.
All right. Thank you for that.
Man, Rodrigo really wants to know.
Adventist dies on Sabbath at McDonald's.
Lost or
saved? Jose, one minute to you.
Another fun question. All right. Um,
listen, the reality is again like any
other commandment, it's like saying, uh,
if someone died the moment they told a
lie, are they going to be saved? Well,
again, that that's not how grace works.
All right? Um, grace, where sin
abounds, grace abounds much, much more.
And so, I believe that judgment is not
just God judging by the letter of the
law. He's going to judge our motives.
He's going to judge our conscience and
where our heart is in regard to these
things. Where our knowledge is in regard
to these things. And so a Seventh Day
Adventist dies in Mickey D's. I don't
know. That's up to God.
All right, Tony, we will say the same
thing over to you. Yeah, I would say
yeah, I would say if you died at Burger
King, he's definitely lost. Uh but u
yeah, I mean again, I guess that that
question is about uh an Adventist who's
working on the Sabbath. Um I I see no
problem if you know even Christians who
have to work on Sunday if you hold to
the Lord's day, which I do. Now, not as
a Sabbath. I don't see the Lord's Day as
a Sabbath. This is where even Miles and
I would disagree. Um but the the point
being that uh I don't see the observance
of any particular day as binding on us
in the new covenant and therefore this
would this would be to me this was would
not be an issue of
salvation. All
right. This is kind of a question.
Gentiles debating covenant established
only with Israel. Shaking my head. Uh, I
guess you could frame that as, uh, was
the covenant only made with Israel,
something in that regard. Jose, you have
one minute.
Yeah. So, if you listen to my opening
statement, and I think I said it in my
rebuttal, too. I mean, look, here's the
problem. The new covenant was made with
Israel as well. Read Hebrews chapter 8,
Jeremiah 31. That's another part of what
I believe is an inconsistent argument.
All right. So, when we're looking at
this to say, oh, that's the covenant
because it was with Israel. Hebrews 8
states multiple times, I am making a
covenant with the house of Israel with
the house of Judah. I mean, either we
need to realize that both the old and
the new covenant invited Gentiles to be
a part of that. I mean Isaiah 5 uh6
talks about Gentiles who want to join
the Lord and keep the Sabbath day holy.
They could get circumcised even in those
days and do that as well. So I think
both covenants invite Gentiles to join.
It's a matter of how.
All right. Thank you for that. Jose
Tony, anything you want to add? One
minute. Yeah. Yeah. The Mosaic covenant
was made with Israel. There's no doubt
about that. That's why uh John 1:17, the
law came through Moses, but grace and
truth came through Jesus Christ. And
also uh we we notice in Ephesians 2 that
Paul tells us that that dividing law
wall that kept the Gentiles out of the
commonwealth of Israel, that that
dividing wall, which was the law of
commandments in writings. Um that kept
us out and Christ had to do away with
that. He had to nail it to his cross.
Thereby breaking down the wall of
partition and taking of the two. He made
one new man. That's the church. The one
new man is the church in Christ. And so
the law kept the Gentiles out. That's
why there had food laws. There was ways
they dressed to keep them distinct from
the nations. Now the new covenant was
made with Israel and Judah. But it had
to be made with them first because the
Messiah came to Israel first. But the
prophets also said that the Messiah
would also be a light to the Gentiles
and therefore it was not just Israel but
by extent it would go to the Gentile
nations as the prophets also predicted.
All right. This individual had another
comment. Gentiles are not under the law
because they never were. But then they
continue by saying, "Hose, please
explain the words in Matthew
15:24 and Romans 11 11 and
25. If you want to take a second to get
there, I don't know if we'll necessarily
be able to get to both of those quickly,
but Matthew
15:24 and Romans
11 11 and 25.
You can begin speaking when you get
there, sir, and you are ready to go.
Yeah, there's no way I'm explaining this
in one minute. I'm going to simply just
state to you uh that when he says, "I
was not sec sent except to the lost uh
sheep of the house of Israel." Of
course, Romans 11 is talking about uh
Israel's election, the remnant, uh
aspects of that nature. Uh I would just
simply state to that that well I mean
Paul made it clear salvation Jesus said
salvation is of the Jews. Paul said uh
for the Jew first and then the Gentile.
And so, uh, when we're dealing with this
aspect, that's why I'm saying when you
see both covenants that were made with
Israel, but Israel was meant to be the
vehicle by which the covenants went to
the rest of the world. Isaiah, I think
49 points that out that they were to be
a light to the Gentiles, the nations.
And so, even through the remnant, they
also brought the light of Jesus.
Perfect. One minute again, sir. Tony,
anything you'd like to add to that?
Yeah, it adds to what I just said
earlier that Jesus came first for the
for Israel. That's what the prophet
said. He would come to his own, but his
own did not receive him and then he went
then the message would go to the
Gentiles. So, we're not disputing that.
Of course, uh Matthew 15:24 had been
sent only to the lost sheep of the house
of Israel. But, you know, our our our
reader or our our questioner should
check Matthew 28:19 and following. He
now says make disciples of all the
nations. So it's gone from only Israel
to now all the nations fulfilling the
prophets that he would come first to
Israel and then by extension be a light
to the Gentiles. Paul in Romans 11 is
pointing out that at the end of time and
this is the view that I hold to. He's
pointing out that there is a remnant
among the Jewish people who have come to
believe in Yeshua the Messiah. In fact,
I had a Jewish believer in my church
just yesterday joining us for worship.
But at the end of time, there is going
to be a remaining remnant of Jews that
are going to turn to their Messiah and
all Israel will be saved. Not all Israel
in that every single Jew that's ever
lived is going to be saved, but all of
the remnant, the remaining remnant of
the Jews who believe in the Messiah will
be saved. So you need scripture, not
just part of scripture.
All
right. This person says to Jose,
"Theoretically, if you were promoting a
false prophet on Sabbath, would you be
breaking the Sabbath?"
Yeah, I'm assuming you're you're wanting
to deal with the Ellen White question.
That's a debate for another time. The
only thing I'm going to say to you is
the debate is whether or not she really
is a false prophet. Now obviously uh uh
the arguments that I'm my opponent would
say yes and many others would do the
same thing. Um I would differ with that
under the gift of prophecy, the talents
given. Uh but I do believe that um if a
prophet is a prophet of God, they're
going to speak according to God's word.
Of course, the problem is we don't all
agree right now, as you can tell, on
what God's word actually is saying. And
so, obviously, that's going to be the
lens by which some of us are going to
say, true or false. And so, that's
something we all have to study out and
be honest with God for ourselves.
All right. Thank you, sir. Tony,
anything you'd like to add? Yeah, I
would agree with the premise that I
mean, if you're promoting a false
prophet on Sabbath or whatever, let's
say the Lord's day on Sunday, uh, would
you be breaking the Sabbath or the
Lord's day? Well, yes, you would. Um,
and and so, uh, any promotion of a false
prophet, um, is sinful to God because
it's apostasy. It's the Deuteronomy 13
1-5. It goes on to say that if anyone
amongst you turns away from the Lord
under the Mosaic law, they were to be
executed for apostasy under the Mosaic
law. Thank God we're not under that
today. Um but um I think apostasy um is
was a federal crime under the theocracy
of God uh with Israel. Um so yeah, I
would I would agree with the premise.
Um, but you could also uh you could also
be a heretic and keep the Sabbath. Uh,
there's a lot of Sabotarian groups out
there. There's uh, you know, the
Armstrong cult. Uh, again, with all due
respect, Jose, the 7th Day Advent is our
cult just as much as Armstrong and and
all the other uh, Sabotarian cults.
All
right. Again, another question from
Valkyrie. How can SDAs argue for old
Sabbath when the gospel was only
preached to Gentiles after Jews rejected
it and after Mosaic law was fulfilled?
Acts
13:46-47. Hosea, you can begin.
How can Old Testament when the gospel is
only preached to Gentiles? All right.
Um, see if I understand this. How can
SDAs argue for Old Testament Sabbath
when the gospel was only preached to
Gentiles after Jews reject and after
Mosaic law? Well, really, because we I
we we don't believe that the Sabbath was
just for the Jews. Again, if you're
going to make that argument, the Sabbath
was just for the Jews, then throw out
the new covenant because the new
covenant, the stated words of the new
covenant is that it was with the house
of Israel, the house of Judah. I mean,
if we're going to be true to the words,
but clearly that's what the words say,
but the application is is understood
differently. Hence why we have Gentiles
in the new covenant. And guess what?
There were Gentiles in the old covenant
as well. The fact that the Israelites
didn't complete their full mission, uh,
well, that's what the remnant was for.
All right, Tony, anything you would like
to add to that, sir? Yeah, I would say
that in the old covenant, uh, if you
were to join Israel, you you had to be
circumcised. you you had to be engaged
in the sacrificial system and so on. So
these are two dispensations. They're not
exactly the same here. Uh in the new
covenant, you don't need circumcision.
In the new covenant, you don't need to
come under Moses. We're no longer under
Moses. We're under Christ. And so what
is interesting that Valkyrie points out
here is very interesting. In the book of
Acts, whenever Paul goes on the Sabbath,
he goes to the synagogues to preach to
the Jews on the Sabbath. But after
chapter 18, when they finally kicked him
out and Paul said, "Fine, you, you know,
we turn away from you and now we turn to
the Gentiles, you'll never hear Paul
going back into the synagogue on the
Sabbath." After that break, he goes
directly into the to the Gentile
territories. You don't hear any more
about the Sabbath. So when the book of
Acts mentions the Sabbath, it always
mentions it in the context of Paul's
evangelism to his Jewish kinsmen. Um and
and so this idea that the Gentiles, I
mean, Acts 15, the whole council of
Jerusalem,
the Gentiles be under the law and the
answer was no.
All right, we have three more and we'll
be closing things
out. Question for both. Revelation 11
reveals the ark of the covenant as God's
judges uh as God judges the world. Is
there nine commandments now in the ark
or 10?
this one since it's for both. Tony,
we'll begin with you.
Well, the book of Revelation is
apocalyptic literature. It's not
something that we have to be careful not
to take it literally because if you take
it literally, then Jesus is a lamb in
heaven with uh with uh seven horns and
and seven eyes and he's going around and
he's bleeding uh like a lamb in heaven.
No one believes that. No one believes
that he's a lion with with a mane and so
on. So this language of the ark of the
covenant is speaking of God's uh
presence. It's associated with his
throne. It's the foottool of Yahweh. So
everywhere the ark of the covenant
appears in the Old Testament, it's
referred to as the foottool of Yahweh.
And so in the book of Revelation, it
speaks of his holiness. It's his divine
presence. Uh and so the question of the
commandments being in the ark doesn't
even come up. It's irrelevant. The point
is that this is apocalyptic imagery.
It's talking about God's presence, his
divine presence. And in the context of
Revelation 11, it's talking about the
two witnesses and how God vindicates
them by raising them up and and raising
them to himself. So be very careful.
This is we're not talking about a
literal arc in time.
All right, Jose, the same to you. Now,
um I'm not so sure that I would totally
agree with that because I mean the book
of Hebrews mentions that there is a
literal temple. So the book of
revelation is meant to be taken symbolic
when it sounds symbolic. I mean that's
one of the things that I teach on. If
something sounds symbolic, guess what?
It's because it is. If something is
sounds literal, especially when other
scripture points to the fact that there
is a literal sanctuary in heaven. All
right? and that it was that that Moses
took as the pattern for the sanctuary
uh that he put in the
wilderness, then it stands to be that in
heaven there is a sanctuary. There is an
ark of the covenant and I do believe
that God will judge according to the
laws that define sin which are the ten
commandments.
All right. Thank you for that, sir.
Faith asks why we see nowhere in the New
Testament we see no Christians observing
the Sabbath. Instead, prayer and
breaking the bread only happened on the
first day. Tony, your thoughts on that,
sir? Yes, and that's that's a very good
point. You don't see Christians
worshiping on the Sabbath. Whenever you
see them gathering, Acts 20:7 and on the
first day of the week, we Luke uses the
plural we. We that is we Paul and the
others we we ca we gathered together to
break bread and breaking the bread is an
idiom for the Lord's supper for having
the eukarist and that was done on the
first day of the week and then of course
in 1 Corinthians 16:2 Paul says he lays
down a rule for all the churches that on
the first day of the week they are to
set aside these funds that were to go to
the Jerusalem church but he says this is
what I commanded the churches of Galatia
and you the Corinthian church as well.
So why the first day of the week?
people. The implication is that this was
a habit that these Christians would
assemble on that day. And so on that
day, they'd take up an offering for the
saints in Jerusalem. Also remember in
John 20, Jesus rises on the first day,
appears to his disciples on the first
day of the week, reveals himself on the
first day of the week, wishes them
shalom, he gives them peace. It's on
that day he breathes the Holy Spirit on
them. On that evening, he appears and
then a week later, following Sunday, he
appears to Thomas.
All right, Jose, you have one minute.
Listen, here's the reality. Acts chapter
2 says that they met every day for the
breaking of bread every day. I I don't
have a problem. You can meet any day of
the week to worship God. That's the
Bible's clear on that. I hope you're
worshiping God every day. I teach my
people, we're supposed to be 7day
Christians, not seventh day Christians
alone. And so worshiping God every day
is important. That's got nothing to do
with keeping the Sabbath holy. And I
would also add Leviticus 23 makes it
clear that the Sabbath was supposed to
be a day of holy convocation. That was
already given in Moses's explanation of
the fourth commandment. So meeting
together, coming together was part of
keeping the Sabbath day holy. But that
doesn't take away from your ability to
meet every day of the week. The idea
that Christians saw a special something
in the first day of the week. I don't
have a problem with that
either. All
right. This individual asks, "Should we
impose the punishment of breaking the
Sabbath commandment or the commandments?
And if we do uh if we don't impose the
punishment, does that mean the law now
has a different purpose?" Jose, we'll
start with you.
All right. So, that's a good point. It's
something we discussed before. Look, the
law also said if you committed adultery
that those adulterers should be stoned.
We're not stoning people today who
commit adultery. All right? We're not
putting to death people. We're not doing
the eye for an eye, tooth for a tooth
for someone who bears false witness. If
you lied about someone and and they
found out, you got whatever you wanted
coming towards them. All right? And so
what it shows is that parts of this
Torah total law had certain
applications, certain purposes, and when
they met their purposes, then we move
on. But God's ten commandment law always
stands as a definer and a foundation of
defining sin.
All right. Thank you for that, sir.
Tony, you have one minute. Well, I like
the way uh Jose said that because he
sounded like me there. Once it serves
its purpose, then we move on. Doesn't
mean that God contradicts himself. And
so, a lot of these moral commandments
had moral uh ex execution laws to them.
And so, adultery, you had to execute
adulterers. We don't do that today. Um
you had to execute them for Sabbath
breaking. We don't do that today. And so
how do we apply that today? If we don't
have those those those imposition of
execution uh under the law then how do
we impose them today? Well think of for
example uh by breaking the law the
Sabbath you were to be executed. The the
Sabbath represents Christ by by
profaining Christ by rejecting Christ
you will be eternally separated from
God. uh by becoming an apostate.
Deuteronomy 13:1-5, by turning against
the Lord, becoming a rebel, becoming an
apostate, you are not just going to you
would have experienced physical death in
in in the Mosaic law, but in the new
covenant, you face eternal separation
from God.
These moral laws do have New Testament
implications as well.
All right, two more. I know we said we
were done. Folks, please send through no
more super chats. We have two more and
we are closing things down.
Rodrigo says, "Adventists sin every day
like everyone else." I'm assuming this
is for you, Jose. Do you believe that
when an Adventist sins, they are
breaking the
Sabbath? I'm kind of assuming that he's
saying that are you sinning when you
break the Sabbath? That's how I'm
understanding that. I mean, obviously,
not every time you're sinning you're
breaking the Sabbath. I mean, if you're
committing adultery, you're not
necessarily murdering, but you are
breaking the law. And the wages of sin
is death. I think that's what the Mosaic
law was teaching when people had to die
for doing whatever they did. The wages
of sin is death, but the gift of God is
eternal life. And so, uh, do I believe
that people who know what God's law
teaches and choose to
disobey, are they sinning? Yes. Is it
dangerous? Yes. Is there
grace to bring you into harmony with
God? Amen. Yes, there is.
All right, Tony, your one minute. Yeah.
I mean, I since I don't believe
Sabbathkeeping is is relevant in the new
covenant, I would say that um that the
child of God is still fallible, that
we're not perfect. Uh we still sin. Uh 1
John 1:8-9, if we confess our sins, he
is just and righteous to forgive us. And
1 John 2:1, we have an advocate with the
father if we sin. And and so the
righteousness that we have in Christ,
we've been justified by faith by by by
believing in Christ, by trusting in his
finished work on the cross, that is
finished and that we have assurance of
our salvation. We have a blessed
assurance, but that does not mean that
we do not still sin. We could still fall
into sin, but there's this ongoing
familial uh forgiveness that God offers
us in 1 John 1:7. The blood of Jesus his
son cleanses us from all sin. It's a
present indicative tense. It continues
to cleanse us from sin. And so this is a
reality that uh that we continue to sin.
We are for our sins, but there is
forgiveness in Christ.
All right. And the last one of the
night, this individual asks, "God wrote
the law on stone and on paper. Why do
Adventists stress about his finger? Does
it hold more weight than when it's
written on paper by God?
Jose, final
question. Love the question. Um, the
question isn't why do we stress it? The
question is why does the Bible take the
time to make that clear? I mean, if it
doesn't matter, then it then all we just
need to do is just say God gave Moses
the law and that's it. But clearly, God
takes the time to tell you, I wrote it
with my finger, and I want you to put it
in the ark of the covenant where
mercy and justice embrace. They kiss,
they meet, the mercy seat, the law of
God, they meet together. That embracing,
that kiss is what brings hope to the
Christian. And so stress the finger
thing, ask God why he took the time to
make those distinctions. Thanks for the
question.
All right. And Tony, you have one minute
to close us out, sir. Yeah. 2
Corinthians 3, that which was written on
stone is passing away, and it is being
rendered obsolete. But that which has
been written by the spirit in our
tablets of our hearts, that outshines
the tablets of stone. So the writing of
God on our hearts supersedes that which
is written on stone. That which was
written on stone was a ministry of
death. That which is written by the
finger of God on your hearts is life.
And so instead of me resting in the Old
Testament and going back into the
shadows, back into the ark of the
covenant, back into the ten commandments
and the ark, I want to go to Jesus. I
want to go to the new covenant. I want
to go to him who Moses and the prophets
spoke about. I want to go to him that
all scripture points to. And in him, I
find my righteousness and my
justification and my peace and my
sanctification. And it's my prayer that
you come to know this Jesus and have
blessed assurance in him.
All right. Well, gentlemen, again, thank
you so much for being here and thank you
as well to the audience for being here
as well. We had a good number of people
tonight. Hopefully, this was edifying in
various ways for various people. And may
Christ richly bless you in the grace and
peace one by him and his vicarious death
on the cross for sinners. Until next
time, God bless.
[Music]